welcome ladies and gentlemen to the chess.com
junior speed chess championship we have an amazing
match uh for you guys today between grand masters
nihal saren and andrew tang i'm grandmaster daniel
nerdisky and it is my pleasure to be commenting
today with uh feed a master my client mike how
has your morning been are you as excited as i
am for this match yeah i don't know how i got
chosen for what i think is going to be the most
exciting opening round match uh so i hope to not
disappoint but i would have watched this one as
a fan anyway which means i would not have been
productive so i guess my bosses figured they might
as well hire me so the number one seed against
the top ko qualifier i couldn't ask for much more
absolutely well we all know you're awesome mike so
i think we all know why we're chosen well before
we jump into the action let's take a quick look
at the bracket and i am going to force you to make
some predictions because you are the uh nominated
nostradamus so we have just so many mouth-watering
names uh mike anything catches your eye from
these first rounds any particular players
that you think we should watch uh well what
captured my eye was actually the country of
origin of the players we've got five indians
three americans two russians and two iranians
that's kind of a different balance of power
than i might have expected unfortunately for the
two russians they seem to be playing each other
now as far as predictions i'm a little bit
hesitant because uh you know first of all i want
to look silly but also if there's one thing they
teach you in journalism school it's you know try
to keep your impartiality so can i let you know
in three hours who's a favorite in this match is
that okay that's fine but i think uh we already
have a model that is ready so it is too late uh
that's true this is a statistical model but as you
can see um we've got uh well the number one seed
is actually seemingly going to be the favorite
statistic i can't believe that can you believe
the number way let me get that straight a number
once you but we have nihal sarah he is of course
an absolute beast but we will get into that but
all of these other names i mean martha rose and
muksud lou they are not only amazing chess players
but blitz and bullet juggernauts so i mean this is
just gonna this is obviously going to be very very
close so this yeah take a look at it the one of
the predictions is for savion to get to the finals
i'm not sure sevion gets past the first round um
that's kind of i think that's one of the nice
things about the junior speed chess championship
not that the regular speed chess championship is
not worth watching but one versus 16 matchups in
the regular speed chess championship are usually
just magnus toying with somebody ricardo twins
right exactly but we will be incredible yeah well
let's take a quick look at the format and some of
the logistics so everyone is on board we have of
course 16 players uh each match consists of three
hours yeah and we have a 90 minute segment of five
plus one as with most speed chess championship
matches 60 minutes of three plus one and thirty
minutes of bullet everything played with a
one second increments um and that is pretty
much standard uh standard fare yeah like any
thoughts about that well the increment i think
uh probably negatively uh affects tang because
tang plays hyper bullet in fact is there something
called ultra bullet i just had to learn what the
term was for 15 second chess i mean 30 second
chess is already a bit of a weird thing but
peng is probably negatively impacted by that but
sarna is also so fast as well i wonder could we
allow the players to mutually agree to abandon
the one second increment if they both so choose
i i think neither will be against it to be
completely honest with you mike yeah they're
so incredibly fast both of them in their own way
and you know people might be a little bit more
familiar with andrew's speed but but nihal is well
as of a couple of days ago he was number one on
chess.com bullet with over 3200 i shudder to think
what his rating is now with the update uh so he is
and i've played him many times myself he's
incredibly strong uh so so this is actually
going to be very very close and we are about
to have liftoff here any second now not to say
the five minute section is going to be boring
they're also both very very strong players mike
yeah in fact nihal was a mere fm a couple of
years ago when i interviewed him at the isle
of man tournament and everybody was saying you
know prague was getting a lot of attention but
everybody was saying keep your eye on nihal and
i'm a historically horrible judge of talent but
those people of course were not wrong he didn't
actually beat his first gm until four years ago
which is a little strange to you know wait till
you're 12 years old to be your first gm over the
board but of course now he is one himself he is
the number one seed in the tournament i'm curious
donya is he the number one classically rated
player as well i know he's the number one seed
that's based on some some blitz and bullet ratings
right and by the way we do now have liftoff and
i actually think is max lou maybe higher a little
bit higher than what what exactly is nihal's feed
is he over 26.50 as we have a very fashionable
line of the queen's camera here on the board
i'll look that up for you but since
we're right into the action we will get
popular stuff nowadays yeah do you think uh
players a little more conservative in the
opening round matches i mean the fact that white
has already gotten rid of the tension with c4 c5
is it uh is it like the worst thing in the world
to lose your first game as white and that's why
you might see this move it definitely i mean i've
noticed this commentating a lot of these matches
uh there is this you know you begin conservative
you definitely don't want to jump out to a
three zero four zero deficit that is crushing
and so we see knee hall is a jack of all trades
i've seen him play literally everything under the
sun and that i think is a hallmark mic of young
players these days they used to have a narrow
repertoire i remember when i was growing up
i was only playing one opening nowadays
they're playing everything and they're
playing everything at an increasingly young age
i kind of like white's position here in the early
going with this pawn on c6 being as strong as
it is vikings could consider just bishop d395
something tells me this is still theory and
i'm completely out of date but i do like what
nihal is doing here i hope we get different
openings you know i just got done in july
being the commentator for the chess kid youth
speed chess championship 10 years and younger
and those kids would get trained on one
opening and play it for three hours well
actually the match is only two um and nothing
against them they're going to have more limited
repertoires when they're 10. so the nice thing
is today when they play an opening that i know
nothing about i probably won't see it again
so i only have to be stupid for five minutes
yeah i actually wonder if it's going to be one
of those matches where they play the same thing
every single game uh or or they vary
so andrew settling into a thing here
um he's got some problems to solve the spawn
on c6 is like a splinter in black's position
one thing to consider here would be bishop a6
trying to lighten the level he goes a4 so he
limits white's ability to push his pawns on the
queen side now bishop b5 here mike that looks
pretty scary to me i maybe andrew wants to meet it
with something like bishop a6 um something to this
effect but then white can just capture on a4 the
id bishop a6 being to stop white from castling but
this definitely doesn't work right off the bat i'm
not seeing anything wrong with bishop b5 yeah i
think the reason black played a4 was because if
b4 was allowed to happen and then the pawn got
to b5 as well if black could never accomplish
the e5 break black's playing without a piece
so you're exactly a4 to be able to take on poisson
to always at least be able to trade bishops on a6
at the very least yeah and as i'm thinking about
this it occurs to me that maybe what does known
bishop oh bishop b2 that was a mouse slipped
by me i think this should be five rook a5 maybe
with that same idea bishop takes a4 bishop a6
i'm trying to stop away from castling but here
look at this rogue on a5 it gets snapped off by
that pawn so maybe nihal trying to figure out
what is wrong with bishop e5 but andrew is such
a tricky player he usually has something in mind
yeah now if you play bishop b5 and then you
get your queen onto the same diagonal then
essentially what you're trying to do is play
an entire game based on one bad piece and to
borrow a phrase from grand master sam palatnik the
bishop on c8 and i apologize for the first russian
accent is a thick buffalo and when you have a
sick buffalo it makes the whole herd sick um
i don't mean to get too close to our our present
pandemic this is something was saying well before
the coronavirus but uh when you make one piece bad
it can often ruin an entire position and this is
going to inhibit all of black's development if
the bishop on ca doesn't find a home no i mean
your russian accent was very good mike i approve
very much yes okay but okay what does uh android
do in this position because it takes a fourth
yeah i mean the question is really maybe black
doesn't do anything and he waits for white to take
on a4 and then goes bishop basics and again stops
tries to prevent white from castling that
seems to me to be the only thing that
black can do to compensate maybe some like 98 try
to get this knight to d6 now this this does not
look good to me and some something definitely has
gone wrong here in the opening for andrew as he
is burning into his clock using up almost half
of it now by move 13. and what i would ask you
is does white even want the pawn or does white
just want to control the diagonal leading to a6
um i think he just wants to control
that diagonal i mean and the thing is
the terrifying thing is white will not even
have to rush taking on a4 as you say you can
castle first and lessen the impact of black's
control over that diagonal i mean is black just
lost here i i'm just struggling to understand
you know what what uh andrew can even do here
you know what's funny donya uh it's time for me
to record my next chess kid video and there's
not many topics i haven't covered yet but
wedge pawns is a topic i've not covered and
i'm just going to take a little note about this
position because i need fodder for my videos and
i think that c6 pawn counts as a wedge fun very
interesting that's one of those concepts mike
that's not often talked about but can be the
secret sauce in a lot of positions i like it
um i approve not that anybody cares but but i
approve the video uh so here we have a5 andrew
settling on it nihal again trying to figure
out is anything wrong with just taking the pawn
um maybe andrew can try to liberate his position
a little bit with b5 and b4 uh and if you take on
b4 well then i take with check and then i can
play that favorite move of ours bishop a6 so
maybe that's the idea and nihal definitely there's
some he takes and we have b5 so the thing is white
can drop his bishop back in castle and give back
the extra bond that is also something to consider
let's see what new when he all does here i wonder
if bishop b3 b4 if white plays a4 and just says
i'm going to try to win every end game that ever
existed but he still loses control of the diagonal
no i love that though because maybe now you can
swing your knight around to d3 use the knight as a
blockader and then castle not that it's that
important to castle it's not like black has a
raging attack here but we have some action yeah
we have bishop c2 before you could still go a4
and redirect the bishop to d3 but you'd have to be
careful about not losing the a4 pawn in that case
so some problems to solve for sure for nihal um
a4 bishop a6 and then again he's not in a big
hurry so maybe he doesn't even need to castle
that quickly funny comment in the chat nihal
may be sleepy it is hard to accommodate a time
that works for both the central u.s time zone
and the indian time zone so i don't think it's
that late in india though although that is one
piece of intel that i did not do before the
match it looks like it's about 9 30 in india
um so i don't know nihal's sleep schedule i
don't think that's too late for most 16 no
no no i don't think so i think this is when he
starts his his blitz sessions on chess.com but i
speaking of the times i always had this problem
with my chess coaches because they were always in
europe somewhere in europe and so it was usually
at my morning and their evening let's just say i'm
not a morning person and let's just say i had some
angry coaches i'll share some stories later mike
but that was never fun for me even as a kid well
knee hall dipping by the way below a minute almost
yeah i do like what black has done here because
if there's one thing i've learned about playing
strong grand masters is that you can't allow
them every trump in the position you have to
do something to free your position so the fact
that black is offered upon to get activity is
a no-brainer you just can't allow yourself to
get overwhelmed slowly yeah you simply cannot
be bite in your time you have to do something
now um if white goes a4 i think when what is
changed my mouse this has been happening now in
my bullet games and bla white ghost b3 maybe what
nihal's worried about is this knight swinging
over to c3 i'm not sure that's truly something
to worry about but maybe nihal is trying to
you know not allow any kind of counter play
and he does end up castling so something he didn't
like there now i still think he's better mike
as you mentioned this wedge pawn definitely gives
him an advantage there's no doubt in my mind about
that yeah probably easier though to give the pawn
back and play this position with 40 seconds left
rather than having to worry about okay when
the knight comes to c3 you know how do i uh
manage my position so maybe he just bailed out
and said i can't be worse in this position i
can play it more quickly with 40 seconds left
right and now another decision for andrew which
pawn which piece does he take the pawn with um
if you take with the bishop you might get pinned
so from that perspective maybe you take the rook
now not that that pin is so scary um maybe you go
after this maybe you play bishop a6 first and try
to gain a tempo that does seem pretty reasonable
i'm not sure i love nihal's decision
to be honest of giving this pawn back
and here we do have bishop a6 bishop d3 white is
always going to be better in end games because of
this pawn but with every trade it seems to me
that the load on black's position is less than
like yeah now the c7 pawn is starting to become a
thought in white's idea and of course the c7 pawn
is basically the game because if you get a pawn on
c6 that's unrivaled it's going to be hard to stop
right completely agree um maybe yeah so maybe 95
queen v7 here for white this is going to be a time
scramble they are both now at 30. seconds and is
this a surprise to anyone and the increment though
mike is going to introduce definite nuance
into these time scrubs as we've seen before
by the way if we were to reconstruct this match as
a straight up one minute bullet match no increment
would tang be a going away favorite or you
know he's so much more well known than sauron
but it's i think you know a little bit more about
nihal skills so uh they do have an increment but
in a pretend world where they don't who would be
the favorite i would have to go with andrew now
take this with a grain of salt it's so close
they're both so incredibly strong but to me
andrew seems just a little bit more experienced
in those time scrambles and a little bit faster
and i think that would impact positively now here
we see neat hall 10 seconds to 19 from andrew
so let's watch as this game uh comes to its
conclusion we have andrew activating his pieces
rook c3 to be considered there is queen's
queen tension and nihal grabs the queen now
he can try to go after the c pawn with rook
b7 he's got seven seconds this is where the
respective internet service providers um start
to get a little bit nervous g5 okay do we have
a fizzling out here again i think white's better
mike you can go knight c5 two seconds gotta make
a move though oh this is actually wondering
if you could play rook b7 there as an ex
as a sacrifice because it was hard to guard the c7
pawn but i don't think it was worth the risk maybe
knight d7 too knight b7 also that b7 square i like
that idea but he's doubling on the b-file maybe
he's preparing that sacrifice three seconds and
we're going nicely for going after the pawn rook
b7 now rookie in two seconds of the clock he's won
the pawn videos knight takes c6 e4 definitely knee
hall pushing here this is so hard to play for
andrew rookie somebody's trying to hunker down
knight coming around to b4 what is going on here
andrew trying to hold this together d5 looks like
it's going down it is but now he's going to
go rook a2 rook d7 checking rook g1 though oh
he pre-moved badly now takes some geeky seven he
didn't expect that wasn't the worst free move in
the world definitely not i've seen worse but this
might be a draw now now andrew's the one pushing
he's got the active rook he has got the act of
broke now nehal has to be careful with one second
second on the clock but this should be a draw mike
rick on e5 and we have fizzle out here in a draw
yeah and let's see if they agree to it if they try
to blitz each other with a one second increment
doesn't make much sense right blitz each other
exactly and we have peace it appears well king f7
would not make make sense that would blunder the
pun with check we have a draw in the first game
and wow it seems to me that nihal definitely had
that opportunity in the opening maybe that idea to
castle was a little bit on the conservative side
and didn't make the most out of the advantage but
you know nothing disastrous for for him obviously
yeah and not so bad for white you know you pushed
you pushed you were the aggressor but you got a
little short on time and you bailed out and uh
i think it was it was a managed game it
wasn't a game where white took undue risks
right i i completely agree um and it's so early
in the match here we have a nimzo indian with
andrew's queen c2 now i brought this up in the uh
qualifiers andrew is someone who and we discussed
this with nihal but andrew always plays the
same stuff he plays his classical repertoire
even in blitz and bullet which has its positives
and negatives he knows it very well but it is
easy to prepare against including this queen c2
nimzo he plays this exclusively he's played it
against me a million times and nihal choosing
an interesting line where his queen has come
out to f5 again we have a pawn on a4 that
pawn is weak if you bring the bishop back
white could consider snagging it but white's
king's side is undeveloped so this looks like
a pretty sharp position in a decision to be made
now by nihal and i was listening to your broadcast
with robert hess on the qualifier on the knockout
qualifier where you said that some players prepare
heavily for these online blitz matches and
some kind of don't they just you know they may
have a loose idea what they want to do i don't
take knee hall as being a wing it tight player
i take knee hall as being a player who
probably did heavily invest some time into
andrew's limited opening repertoire um and come
up with some systems he wanted to play against it
yeah definitely he he's very methodical
he plays you know well-prepared stuff but
at the end of the day you know andrew's ex
just extremely deep knowledge of his lines
might come in handy so we see bishop d6 played
and now a decision to be made by ander does he
take the point i would say no because of knight
e4 this just seems a little bit fishy to me um
maybe you just go e3 and then bishop
d3 and i feel like white is probably
slightly better here i mean honestly
with the possibility of going e4
black on the other hand he can try to
break through on his own with e5 so
we'll see how this hap how this um i think i see
why this fails uh but can you tell the fans why e4
knight takes e4 bishop d3 does not work although
it looks tempting i think there's a foil but maybe
you can show everybody what that is absolutely uh
but before i do a quick reminder of the schedule
as we work on a very quick uh technical fix
uh it seems that there is a bit of an issue
with the evolve bar so we'll remove it for now
we apologize uh but just to remind people right
now is of course uh the beginning of the main
bracket which lasts almost a month to october 5th
uh and the final is on october 8th at 9am pacific
so capture that day in your calendars right now um
because it is going to be what whoever is going
to be playing like it's going to be epic as we
already see from this match and we have action
heating up in this game we apologize for the
technical glitch i'm not sure what the what
the issue is but hopefully you'll have to put
your trust in the hands of me and and mike i
i know that's terrible but we have to ask for
your understanding you are the eval bar my friend
well i appreciate i'm not sure everybody in chat
shares that belief but i've been playing decently
the last couple of days so give me a chance give
me a chance um okay so we have wow we have queen
c2 on the board the queen hunting for this pawn
but wait a minute is that queen going to get in
trouble there's one line i see e3 takes rook b1
and if the queen starts lining its pockets
you have knight b5 and the queen is trapped
so the hall is playing with fire here what does
he want after e3 maybe knight a5 involving the
knight not sure definite stuff to calculate
here for andrew and andrew has gone queen a2
yeah the b-pawn is the classic poisoned
pawn but there must have been something
he didn't like about allowing the queen to
capture it because you're putting your queen
in an awfully defensive spot and you're relieving
black of any need to ever guard the a4 pawn
that's exactly right um so it's kind of a
moral victory there for neal does he go e5 now
this might be the window of opportunity
but whoa mike after rook c1 queen g6
white can go knight h4 and the queen of straps
like yeah on g6 so still he's got to be careful
so maybe he goes queen b3 there but then we
might have the case of a weak pawn or another
wedge on v3 so the hull's definitely calculated
i can guarantee he's calculating e5 right now
there are alternatives he can well are
there alternatives i don't know maybe 94.
very very sharp position here and i would
expect them to labor out of the opening because
you know people often say chess players are
great at pattern recognition but only patterns
that we know of there aren't very many games
your queen's on a2 there's a black queen on c2
where she can get trapped on different wings of
the board there's a pawn on g4 so just like i'm
struggling to come up with familiar patterns
in this position yeah the players are probably
needing to make sure too because these queen
traps are coming out of nowhere they really are
and you bring up a great point which is the more
unconventional the position the harder it is to
to detect these things the more thinking time
is required as we see again by move 13 uh knee
hall has dipped below half of his time used
and andrew also two minutes 44 seconds so
a lot to think about here in the opening now i'm
looking at this position i'm wondering what else
there is other than e5 this move knight e4 the
point is after rook c1 you can take the knight
on c3 counter attacking white's queen you can't
take back with a pawn because of the pin you can't
take with a bishop because the rook is hanging
so white does drop a piece here so this might be
one way to ensure better queen safety uh but it
comes at the cost of not liberating that bishop
and we have knight a5 so nihal choosing to
direct his knight to b3 or is he securing
potentially that square for his queen roxy one now
will force queen b3 but i've got a new best friend
user b handleman in the chess.com tv chat says
i trust mike not sure about donya i'm not sure
about your honesty there but uh somebody's looking
for some sort of premium membership that i'm not
giving away but you got your name announced
on air that's probably what you're going for
that yeah you you sniff that right out so we have
e3 now so we have again the tension between the
queens does you all capture the queen i don't
think there's any need to do that immediately
yeah as we see him just developing bishop comes i
quite like what he's that bishop is not going to
come to b6 i quite like what he's chosen here uh
directing that bishop to c6 to the long diagonal
um mike your early recommendation of going e4
i kind of like that more i feel like black is
getting the upper hand gear uh bit by bit yeah i'm
just not used to positions where your pawns on g4
and i'm trying to figure out how that
relates to my evaluation of the position
i could even see a situation where white plays
queen b1 intentionally avoiding the trade because
the black queen is going to be vulnerable in some
ways when the light squared bishop finds activity
um i'm not sure if we'll find a third way to
trap the black queen one day but uh it could
happen maybe i'd be three but i've shown a sample
line definitely we could see a way that this could
backfire um but yeah this might be the best that
white can do now andrew with with one minute that
is just going to be the narrative we're going
to see a lot of time scrambles in this match
there's no doubt about that yeah i'm guessing also
dona both players are more comfortable draining
their clock down to 30 seconds because of their
but their skills and their experience playing
games that have less than one minute to start
the time yeah they're they're just so used to
it and um is it sort of a compulsion to do
it i think at some point there is a certain
rush and i can attest to that that comes with
not having any time by move 16 and playing on
increment that there is a certain adrenaline rush
that that awakens in you um not that you do it
deliberately but you know there might be a little
bit of that at play yeah but you know we all have
friends in life that always seem to be the ones
that get themselves into dramatic situations
and at some point you're like this person is
seeking out the drama and so that is so true
that is very true and we have bishop coming
to c6 as we expect now probably castles to
be expected here from penguin um and when i say
penguin he is so known by that moniker now i feel
very comfortable just saying that it doesn't sound
weird um that's what he's always been by the way
how does tatev feel about the number one penguin
being andrew because you know tata's got a big
attachment to the penguin name as well that is
true now that i think about it well i don't know
if we bring in todd and we've got to bring
my brother he's a big fan of penguins as well
i'm sure he's watching the broadcast
right now he is terribly offended
but uh you know we got to give andrew some credit
he is after all a wizard but he is in trouble here
25 seconds look at nihal laying it on now knight
c4 threatening the v21 now if you take on c4
you're going to have big problems with this knight
on f3 so that's out of the question and we have
knight to d1 bringing the knight back now andrew
trying his best to ward off this attack yeah
d2 you have to take with the king or can
you take with the knight you can't take
with a knight because you hit the queen and then
people move now black is still doing fine here
but i wouldn't do that if i were knee hell i
would try to find a way to keep this knight
on c4 maybe go b5 but then we might have that
third wave of traffic this time on d5 on b3 it
might escape to d5 but then you have bishop f3
and with the bishop amazing what if the knight
takes d2 knight takes and the queen relocates
to d5 not b6 like a more active square but then
you still might have that bishop f3 move got it
yeah and then you might root out that bishop so
i don't see exactly a good move for new hall
here and apparently neither does he because he
now has depth below 30 seconds and maybe the
best that he can do is in fact do to take on
b2 drop the queen back and save some time he's
taken on f3 which does make sense because if
bishop takes f3 he can force white's king out
to d2 uh which is something you hit on mike but
we have now e5 so he's opening up the center
trying to exploit the weakness of this gang
ten seconds out for andrew and buckle your seat
belts we have another time scramble on our hands
yeah white needs to find a safe file for the king
i'm not sure which one he wants queen to see he's
trying to trade queens nihal could could take on
d4 he's still better in the end game but queen b6
keeping the queens and andrew okay now he
drops his king back maybe evacuates it to g2
i don't think he's actually much worse if he
manages to do that amazing he's brought the king
out he's tasted fire but then now he's bringing it
to the king's side c6 defending the pawns bringing
the knight back out andrew's doing fine all things
considered rook a5 might consider nihil trying to
stop him from coming to the king side and the king
is going to get to g2 just like he said dania and
it looks reasonably safe take on c3 maybe and then
come to d2 at the end you know biting his time
knight to d5 we have more trades we have another
draw and opposite color bishops usually favors the
attacker queen g6 is an idea but it's just an
idea at the moment doesn't do anything but now
rook d7 you kind of called it what does nihal do
three seconds rook d7 and the tables have turned
bishop f7 okay very good move by nina
trying to trade queens take what the rook is
is it gonna be made bishop d3 is made it's made
if he if he checks on d3 will he see it he does
wow what a turn of the tables and andrew defending
and then finding the opportunity to jump onto the
attack and now with a one point lead amazing stuff
mike yeah that was great and a perfect example of
how when you get to the middle game with opposite
colored bishops it's like having an extra piece
in the attack and because of the nature of black's
pawns the f7 pawn was easily attackable but white
had pawns on f2 and e3 which made the black's
dark-squared bishop not terribly useful in the
attack on the white king that's not one of those
features you have even time to consider basically
when you're in a time scramble but that's that's
playing with fire that's what happens you get down
to these um positions with 10 seconds left you
don't really have time to figure out who's going
to be favored in those types of positions exactly
and uh you bring up a good point here when you're
on the defensive and you have to deal with
concrete threats that can be one of the
hardest things to do in time pressure and i guess
our query our question about whether openings
would be repeated well it seems to be answered
here we have another one of these queens we get
andrew will definitely have to change what he did
in the opening right now they're still repeating
all of the same moves mike
i'm a little bit surprised
yeah and it's way too early to call this but if
you're looking for a historical since you're a
history major donya a historical time where a 16
beat a one well it's only happened once in the
history of the ncaa basketball tournament and it
just so happened to be a school that's more known
for its chess championships that's university
of maryland baltimore county as a 16 seed beat
virginia and this is a true story in the locker
room the basketball players were asked about this
historic moment and they said well we're just
trying to keep up with our school's chess team
because university maryland baltimore county yep
they won a couple of national collegiate titles
and so chess has sort of paved the way in a
weird way for 16 seats to beat number one seeds
incredible story wow and it all comes together
yeah um there's actually another way that three
of the four people on this call are related dania
and i are both broadcasting from charlotte and
andrew tang got his final grandmaster norm
in charlotte so forget what copernicus said
the center of the universe is charlotte it
absolutely is i can totally confirm that
and uh wow that's i can't get my head but that
is a really really cool stat i of course the
upset the sports upset that is closest to my heart
is when the golden state warriors i of course am
from the bay area um and of course best wishes to
everyone right now in the bay area stuff you know
suffering through very very tough conditions with
the fires but i i do remember when the warriors
beat the mavs in the first round of the playoffs
um i think it was 2007 and the warriors were the
eighth seed mavs were the top seed and i think
that was one of the only times in nba history
i'm just trying to one up you mike with my sets
but i don't think i ever well that was really cool
wow what else is really cool is the pressure that
nihal is putting a black's position yeah i'll
just close this down you by saying steph curry
is from charlotte but let's get back to chess
that is he is from charlotte
that's true he went to davidson
um in any case so 95 and again white putting
pressure on black's position this knight
potentially coming to d7 it's a different kind
of pressure this time andrew is not struggling
with the weakness of the a-pawn nor is he
trying to prevent white from castling but
i mean maybe i'm not understanding something but
i just to me these positions are so hard to play
especially in blitz i know this line is
popular but it's like i get so cramped
yeah and the chances of the a4 pawn being weak
are several orders of magnitude higher than
the c6 pawn being weak and the pawn on a4 is only
there to stop the white pawn from bm2 from moving
whereas the pawn on c6 serves all kinds of
functions limiting play the potential to become a
past pawn if c7 becomes weak so if we just isolate
those two pawns we have to say whites you don't
often compare a c pawn to an a pawn but white c
pawn has so much more utility than black's a plan
that's exactly right and we see andrew hunting
for this knight on e5 nihol could consider
something like knight to d7 here which has its own
complicated sort of ramifications he has taken on
a6 first so he's lessened some of the tension now
andrew's probably briefly considering taking on
e5 as an intermediate move i'm not liking that
move necessarily maybe bishop b7 then we have to
consider this line with some potential stacks
on h2 so there is something to consider here
um and if you take on a6 maybe nihol just wants
to push out black's knight and this rook on a6 is
undefended that could breed some tactics something
like queen d3 so again white is definitely better
here and andrew does go for bishop takes e5 um
very interesting decision here and now the ball
is in the all score does he go for this line
but should be seven and bishop takes a8 with a
lot of complexity here maybe andrew just wants to
draw his bishop back and go on the counter attack
a little bit skeptical about that mike but
maybe he sees something there i was trying to
make that line work for black as well but once
white's g2 pawn gets to g3 um i don't see how
you break through because white's queen is very
close to the king's side as well unless there's
a double sacrifice on g3 but then really you're
just going for a draw right and i could actually
not take the bishop and go the queen e2 yes
exactly right so i'm a little bit puzzled as to
what andrew has in mind um one thing he might be
considering is to take on e3 and just say okay
i'm going to give up the exchange but i'm going to
have this beautiful knight on on e4 and whatever
it is nihal didn't like the look of it he goes for
bishop takes c5 alternatively he could have queen
g4 okay so now he could have just said here i
have the initiative i'm safe threatening checkmate
either forcing black snipe back or forcing black
to make a big weakness on the king side of the g6
yeah i would have liked to have seen the imbalance
of the exchange sacrifice in fact andrew tang
once played magnus carlson over the board at the
world rapid championship and magnus sacrificed in
exchange against andrew in a beautiful game um so
maybe i'm drawing a little bit of a force parallel
there but i'm hoping to see a little bit of
imbalance today and we'll see if that comes about
in a future game yeah and we do have is is it an
imbalance to say bishop against knight is that
considered an imbalance i don't even know
yeah i think it's called the minor exchange
by kasparov right bishop for night the minor
exchange yeah i think that is a very memorable
aspire well you wouldn't yeah happen to be
playing anymore but in any case uh we have andrew
dropping his knight back to ea and the knight
actually covers uh two pawns at once now we had
a romanian grand master mihai shuba i think had
this famous quote the bad bishops defend good
pawns here we kind of have a case of a bad knight
defending good pawns well i don't even think these
pawns are good either so forget i said okay i just
forget it strike it off the record but i think
white is better white is the one calling the shots
here the problem with these positions is they're
very locked up what exactly is nihal's plan does
he go e4 and open up the center does he sort of
try to make marginal improvements moves like h3
play a russian school of chess you know slowly
what do you think um i was going to try to play e4
i wanted to play f4 f5 but f4 fails to f6 and you
don't want to do that right the bishop is trapped
so yeah maybe you know you have no files for your
rooks and rooks hate pawns as we say in chess
kid land so putting a rook behind the e pawn and
advancing it to open up the position a little bit
for your bishop would be sort of you know baseline
chess what you're supposed to do right neal
taking this lower push he actually trades on d6
whoa that surprises me a little bit that bishop
was the main instrument of pressuring that one
i feel like andrew is breathing a bit of a sigh of
relief after this now maybe white is still better
white can still try to prepare e4 at
his convenience but now he's got to be
careful about this c6 pawn because he could
easily turn from a strength into a weakness
andrew could consider just going f5
and stopping e4 altogether now that
the e5 square is yes it is weak but in name
only white has nothing to occupy it with
yeah and you just made the first point about the
wedge pawn potentially becoming a weakness which
if i ever made a chess kid video we'd have to talk
about the closer you get to an end game the space
advantage means less and less and the fact that
the c6 pawn it's not isolated by the strictest
definition of the chess word isolated but for all
intents and purposes it can't be guarded by a pawn
and it just becomes weaker and weaker if we swap
the queens black's king will just march to d6
and you'll be stuck using a rook to guard the
pawn forever it'll probably be lost in a matter of
you know five or ten more moves it'll
take some time but it'll be lost
yeah and that is would be one of those end games
they show to russian school children you know
position like when people refer to
the russian school of chess i think
playing these kinds of positions very well is
one of the hallmarks of it um even though there
is no like building that is and that's one of the
misconceptions that people have when they think
of that word the russian sculpture they think of
like a stately building in moscow like there's no
building there's no literal institution but it's
more i would say like a style of coaching and a
style of play now here okay so he's redirecting
his queen to a6 but now andrew has to be very
careful that we might be stranded and this
might be a good chance to make stuff happen
weakening black skinny side is knee hull maybe e4
here maybe quickly go rookie one and e4 so he's
got a decision to make i think if he doesn't
go e4 now he won't have another good chance
rook b5 okay now he's defending the
pawn maybe he's swinging the rook to b3
what is going on here but andrew dipping low
on the clock mike yeah again the fewer pieces
on the board the more c6 becomes the the most
important part of the position and in its weakness
but something else that has to be said for the
spawn on a4 blackstroke is kind of tied to it
again i feel like nihal they're playing this
cat and mouse game he keeps trying to decide
should i play e4 and andrew plays e5 wow i
don't know about that he's opening up the
position so if you take on e5 maybe he'll take
back with the pawn he is using the spawn on f6
to his advantage now nihol with the decision does
he keep things closed with something like rook d2
andrew might drive that wedge into e4 i don't
think that bothers knee hall i just think this
might be a draw uh if he allows it to happen but
i'm not sure it's a good idea to take an e5 you've
played a ton of online blitz matches if you're
white here would you ever take into account the
clock situation in your actual move decision
making at this point not with andrew i've done
this so many times i think there's no way even
with increment there's no way he's going to make
it andrew even with no increment with 10 seconds
it can play a very accurate rook end game so
i would play something measured he does take
though okay so maybe he wants to go after this
pawn on d5 um but this took me a lot of time
in his own right now they're about equal on
the clock queen to e6 depending upon pressuring
c6 what to do for white maybe queen to g3 okay
needle dropping his rook back i think it's still
about balanced um i don't think either side has a
measurable advantage i do like what andrew has
done here now he seems to be the one with the
initiative maybe get this rook back to a8 stopping
a potential check on v8 okay he locks the queen of
g5 does knee help play f4 that seems very risky
again let's buckle in and watch things happen here
strange position where the black rooks are not
working together yet they both seem to be doing
more than the white counterparts exactly they're
both on the fake rank but somehow as he as you say
well now neil trying to remedy that situation
pressure maybe queen to h1 and he does rook to
h work takes h5 i know it's not zero esque right
there indeed it did but e4 locks the queen into g2
now he's got that block getting for three seconds
for knee-hill he's definitely worse now he wins
another punt things are spinning out of control
andrew wentworth have six he's threatening rook
takes f2 yeah alekhine's gun coming there it is
oh look at this this has turned around completely
and deep white has lost that c6 upon android
pressing on the kingside h4 look at that defense
shutting white down completely this is mastery
by andrew and he's got a lot more time as well
only a miracle oh he had rook
take c6 there actually maybe
okay h4 and this just seems to be okay nihal
trying trying to complicate things that's
actually a really good move exploiting the sun
definitely broken who definitely missed that
and if h takes what was that queen is overworked
that's the point of the tactic it is look at
andrew's clock three seconds now they've equalized
amazing stuff that me hull oh and the blood is the
rook and after an incredible but still it was
worse of course it was very tough to save that
and andrew prevails again mike two and a half
to a half exactly finale in the live ratings
uh andrew's even catching up a little bit not
that matters for the match you just gotta score
one more point than your opponent indeed that
is incredible and so exciting are these finales
you think five minutes that's so much time but
they're so close in strength that each game seems
to come down to final seconds as they are off
with a london system a vintage weapon for andrew
which he has played for years and years and years
now and uh kind of frustrating for neil on two
accounts number one he was not able to put away
another game where that c6 pawn we both agreed
was a useful pawn and number two he went from
being up a minute to what was it about 20 seconds
to being down uh 15 seconds or three seconds so so
far we are seeing that uh the speed of andrew even
if nihal is pretty fast you know somebody's got
a tesla ludicrous mode and that would be andrew
indeed and uh he is very comfortable in these
structures and what you said i it's interesting
that you can be better but sometimes the mantle of
making a decision is always upon you we saw nihol
there you have to always does he play e4 here does
he break through there that burns a lot of clock
inevitably so in those cases sometimes actually
being worse can be less of a burden than being
better in name only but having to decide you know
sort of when you break through i want to welcome
the many thousands of viewers who have tuned in
this is the opening round of the 2020 chess.com
junior speed chess championship sponsored by
chess kid got to throw that in you can see in
the background behind me that's why you see it and
we've got the number one seed nihal sarin playing
the knockout qualifier andrew tang andrew had to
win a bunch of matches this week just to get here
and so far he's got a two-game lead against
the number one seed he does now i wouldn't say
nihal is terribly concerned he's very measured
he's not very prone to tilt um as far as i know
and uh he's got a decent position here not much to
say and he's go he goes e5 so he's exploiting this
undefended bishop on d3 if andrew takes the hall
will take back and that d3 bishop will hang so
where does ander but the b might have
missed this move now he can play bishop g3
it's not a big problem but knee hall tactically
sharp here i'm actually not sure what nihal will
do after bishop g3 because if you take then
black is left with a slightly weak bond on d6
he does it i just wanted to mention irrespective
of this game donya uh if you have any uh kopecks
or rubles in your pocket that you'd like to bet
the smart money is actually still on nihal sauron
according to the statistical oddsmakers you can
see right there he's still got about a 60 chance
of winning not quite as good as joe biden but uh
you know the smart money is still on nihal star
and at the moment so we all know though that
it's only as good as form and so far andrew
even though he's not gotten some great positions
he's been able to convert a little bit better so
i don't know would you put money on a player
who's down two games and has not been better
in any game yet or not i i don't think so in fact
just give me a second i'm getting a full hey uh
sports bettors yeah you're fired all right that
was that was a terrible performance all right bye
uh i don't know because again i'm i think in terms
of raiding of course knee hall is a better player
classical chess andrew is just so good at blitz
it's just unbelievable the guy is i mean i think
you cannot use the speed a rating as any kind of
measuring stick now i do think this is going to
be a close match i still think this is going
to come down to the bullet um as in i don't
think it's going to be lopsided but i don't think
andrew is or i don't think nihal is the favorite
yeah still pretty early to tell and i don't
have um i mean i used to be the stat guy
for chess.com but uh you know we've we've uh
i've gotten a little bit busy with chess kid
and matt jensen has done a great job with the
stats but the biggest comeback ever back when
we just used to do death matches i believe was
five games i think yaakov norowitz came back
and irena crush was maybe down five games as
well against um one of the kazinsva sisters but
when you get past five i doubt we've had any
one-on-one match where somebody's come back
unless there's just a match i'm not remembering
uh we're a long way away from that but uh you
kind of wanna you wanna put your stop gap
there and say let's not get past four or five
yeah and it appears that nehal is better
here i think andrew has let something
slip look at his king side all these weak
squares on the king side he's trying to
to sort of patch things together but this
bishop more like a band-aid than a permanent fix
uh nihal can try to trade it off with bishop
d6 and then later swing his knight to f4
there's also a potential exchange sacrifice
i'm not sure it's quite time for that yet but
there's stuff to consider here for sure you know
again these dark squares are so so weak for white
so i think andrew was lulled to sleep a
little bit here by the symmetrical structure
but definitely a chance here for knee
hall if he can play this accurately
yeah i'm looking at the player's expressions even
though nihal is well they both look pretty calm
when andrew plays chess what gets me is that
he almost looks bored even though he's playing
so fast does that ever affect your uh do
you ever look at your player's camera in
public one-on-one matches because you've played a
lot of them this summer i do occasionally just to
sort of gauge and i try not to fall in love with
that because sometimes it's either underwhelming
in terms of you know if i play andrew and i'm okay
so tilted i want to say flagged him and andrew's
just has the same expression as if he's up 10-0
um but contrary on the contrary if your opponent
is showing visible signs of frustration that can
give you that little push and that reinforcement
you need so i i sometimes like to gauge uh my
opponent's expression but i wouldn't put too
much stock in it as you say andrew is i mean the
guy is just unbelievably level-headed and uh it's
you know at this point it's become legendary
and for very good reason and perhaps i should
not have dipped my toes in any political waters
but we have a good joke in the in the twitch chat
uh somebody's saying that the tang gang is
well represented so not the yang gang but uh
does that mean that every chess fan gets a uh a
monthly stipend from the government that's what
the tang gang should be behind right well but with
andrew's speed maybe he deserves he's yeah el nino
here he might need some speed to convert this
advantage because he's now taking over a minute
i still like the move bishop d6 um just trying
to trade the bishops and get access to those dark
squares i know it looks a little bit plain vanilla
but this can unravel very very quickly for white
uh with queen g3 and knight f4 yeah it's not
often you see such a horrible bishop for black on
b7 and yet black is probably the one dictating the
action so if black could just fix that one problem
of his bishop on b7 then every advantage would
be his i think indeed and uh as andrew ponder
says move we actually have some really really
cool calculations uh to share with you guys
uh we have the smarter chess match prediction
these statistical predictions so as we can see the
prediction is for new hope to win the five minute
portion i don't know how realistic that is and
he's listed as the favorite here statistically for
all sections including the bullet with a 75 win
probability uh with a pretty lopsided prediction
mike hot take on that i think 75 might be about
right i mean i did demure at the beginning of
the broadcast when you asked for a legitimate
prediction but smarter chess you know that's like
the 538 of the chess world i believe these stats
however again i will go back to what i've said
usually one versus 16 is you know as a chess fan
you're just basically watching nakamura or magnus
just you know play cat and mouse with somebody but
this is a legitimate match as we've seen in the
opening 30 minutes where the 16 i mean one in four
is a real chance you would not you bet your life
on a one and four coin flip and by the way what
coin are you using but um that's what makes you go
intrigued by the junior speed chess championship
yeah literally every match could go either
way that that is just incredible but this
game seems to be spiraling somewhat out
of control for andrew as we've discussed
these weak squares on the king side and part of
the problem could be that if he takes the pawn
take the bishop back which he has to queen c5
check follows then this queen infiltrates to f2
followed by knight f4 this is nasty nasty
stuff for andrew that's why he's thinking
maybe he's trying to find some sudden research he
has to take the bishop if you take to the rook the
same thing might follow i'm not even sure black
needs the rook uh to mount a decisive invasion on
the kings side so he has taken with the rook that
seems to be the lesser evil but again we see he's
sort of dragging his feet here queen c5 follows
i don't see a defense after queen f2 honestly
yeah you know why i mean the only event of
trading rooks if you play king f1 knight g3 is
not made now that's not a ringing endorsement for
playing king f1 but it was an extra possibility
but i think you're spot on uh it's possible
there's multiple ideas but don't play queen eve
i was about to say don't play queen e3 you're
thinking it's the same thing yeah absolutely now
one thing he might be concerned about if queen f2
knight f1 knight of four andrew does have queen c2
he's sort of holding on it's not mate even in
this position queen before it's obviously much
much better for black maybe niel is trying to find
the most accurate way to put andrew away we have
seen time and time again incredible resilience on
display from andrew so you certainly don't want
to be sloppy in the conversion stage and he starts
with knight f4 so he tries to keep things flexible
bishop f1 is likely now maybe he's just gonna go
after this pawn on e5 playing something like queen
d4 uh double attacking the knight of the fun
but in that case andrew does have queen c3 so
it's not completely over and 27
seconds is a little bit concerning
uh for nioh so he's gonna have to be crisp
here it should be noted that if you play
i don't know something weird like king g3 to cover
f2 then the simple queen d4 seems to pick off a
piece because of the multiple pieces on the d file
great point and they are both basically undefended
i'm not sure what's stopping andrew from going
bishop f1 um maybe there's some sort of resource
that i miss maybe quinn f2 i mean it's a slightly
different version and he does it now queen c3 or
queen c2 seems forced to defend the knight then
the hulk could involve that d-pawn send it down
the board open up that bishop um so okay so he
goes g5 he basically accumulates the pressure the
problem for andrews is queen's tied to this knight
so it doesn't seem feasible for andrew to generate
counter play against black's king although
that is something to think about eventually
just dropping that knight on d2 going queen d6 and
throwing your chips into the center of the table
yeah i'm trying to work out a way for a
repetition after queen d6 um i think thinking
about that also i think you should just do
it i mean i think that's the last resort
and he's thinking i i think he's to do it he's
going queen c3 so he's going for c7 similar idea
but i i thought that was actually a chance okay
definitely c7 seems like a no-brainer to me
okay queen c1 so he's still holding back maybe
he's hunting for the right opportunity which is
a bit of a gamble but three seconds for andrew
and again the time scribble so he's going into
passive defense mode he is challenging the hell to
find a way forward but now d392 i do not like that
approach from andrew i think this gives black
a much easier time of it bishop takes age three
and then knight e4 okay he's holding it
together queen c2 you can't take the queen
look at that move from andrew amazing and
he's holding it together he's losing time
wow just like you said donya passive defense you
have to keep solving problem after problem if you
just chuck your chips in as you say you know
what you're trying to do you're trying to just
check or promote a pawn or something it's
much more clear what you're trying to do
that final move bishop f5 also mike was actually
incredibly strong from nihal because he was
threatening to capture the knight on e4
and the queen would lose its defender so
i actually think even objectively it was very very
bad uh for andrew and he's definitely going to
have to adjust that uh in these time scrambles
and uh nihal well he's gaining a point back
and it's only a one point game we have a somewhat
unconventional already here where niho has doubled
back and decided to fee and keto his bishop
so not too theoretical double fianchetto now
on the board andrew putting putting out a slav
structures very solid position black knee hull
not going for the opening advantage mic but just
a slow roll kind of game yeah really weird to play
g3 and e3 that's one of those general rules
you tell kids you know if you've already
played g3 don't play e3 or vice versa because
your bishop can only pick one diagonal so
what do you make of this decision if if white had
played d3 it would just be some sort of like you
know reverse dragon setup but uh why is white able
to get away with this weird structure well the
thing is uh it's it's one of those things classic
modern chess right the concrete i guess specifics
of the position supersede the general principle
usually the reason you're told not to play this
is because these squares that i'm highlighting are
left very weak but because of the way white set
this up his queen is guarding d3 he can take on e5
i would say i'm not a huge fan of this setup but
you know you could try to kind of work around
the edges here with knight a4 knight c5 so it
has i guess it's charm and it could be one of
those provocative openings where you frustrate
your opponent right you think and i should get
an advantage against this and you fail to do
so and then equality can feel like a defeat well
while we've got a little bit of a lull and and don
i'll give you i'll i'll burn 20 seconds for
you a little bit of extra analysis in your head
on my chest kids shows i love to do a little bit
of trivia so i i was trying to think of a trivia
question that related to the first 45 minutes
of chess that we've seen here and i think i've
come up with one although the problem is it's
a little bit subjective and not objective but
here we go i'm going to try it anyway we've been
talking a lot this afternoon about pawn wedges
so my question to all of the fans is which
game which was voted best game of the 90s
by informator i believe it was best game involved
maybe one of the best pawn wedges of all time
wow so don is going to think about it maybe
our fans are going to think about it too
i don't actually know if it was voted best game or
maybe it was like number two game but it clearly
is the best pawn wedge game of the 90s so maybe
i'll restructure my question that way what's the
best pawn wedge game of the 90s so i even got
kudos from from smarter chess on my questions so
anyway so we can be looking at our chessboard
here why everybody uh in the chat tries to tell
me what the answer is well thanks for distracting
me for the rest of the commentary mike let me
distract you and ask you a trivia question
that is a much lower caliber but nihal sarin
was asked if he has a chess nickname um what does
he look like to you mike what would you give nihal
as a nickname based on how much
of a beast he is on the board
uh well i i happen to know what his friends
call him so are you wanting me to reveal that
information i do want you to realize as we
think about the pawn wedge game his friends
call him the devil uh well yeah he's pretty
soft-spoken when i've interviewed him in the past
i'm a little bit surprised by that we didn't
get a chance to ask andrew the same question
because well he just qualified a couple of days
ago and i'm sure he was busy preparing for the
match so if anybody in the chat has a better
name or a non you know friend name for nihal a
more professional nickname he may be open to uh
to different nickname ideas if anybody's got it
in the chat i'm actually looking to see
if anybody has the answer to my question
some people are saying kasparov topolov now
that was in the 90s he snuck in there in 99 but
i don't remember a pawn wedge so is it a single
pawn that you're from or like maybe upon chain
it's absolutely a single pawn and a single pawn
that's what i thought yeah and you and i know when
we talk about pawn wedges we're usually talking
about a center pawn because that literally divides
the board into two hemispheres and this pawn did
exactly that uh i'm looking to see if anybody's
got it i don't think anybody has i'm trying
to check both chats i'm thinking too but i'm
huh you know the game oh wait okay well one of
our staff members smarter chess got it right
i don't know if he was the first
one i actually don't know that game
yeah smarter chess got okay so smarter chess you
win a premium subscription that you already get
forever anyway um it's yvonne chuck youssef 91
where yusupov gets the pawn on e3 and continually
threatens mate on f2 like for the entire game
and sacrifices his entire queen side to force me
i'm going to have to look at that game yeah okay
i'll take over chat while you do a 30 second
find on that game was it one no it was in brussels
91. it was actually a rapid game but yvonne chuck
yusuf off fantastic game it's i'll try to take
over the commentary while you google that um
something in chestnut land that we call the
corkscrew because the bishop on g2 is the key
to popping the white king so when you trade
bishops it's like popping the corkscrew on
a wine bottle and the general rule is if somebody
corkscrews you don't take because you're inviting
the black queen into your territory you want black
to take you so that when your king takes back
you deprive the enemy queen access in this case
to h3 and the other side would be h6 but white's
got the weak pawns in this position except for
a7 which black seems to have just sacrificed
let's see if we can figure out what is going
to happen if the pawn on a7 gets captured
um the idea is what yeah oh b5 oh what a man
it's almost as if he's known as the devil
yeah well i mean what an idea what
a devilish idea i got tricked by it
so e4 by oh no no that's that's andrew the andrew
spring in the trap but he holds the devil for not
falling into it um huh so e4 he's basically
trying to blunt the influence of the rooks
can you take now them
okay but then we take and go like 95 maybe
this looks yeah somehow your knight clears
off the seventh rank with tempo as
you've shown and then b5 resumes it's
it's ugly head mike i'm so sorry to rejoin the
commentary i know you had a great time without me
my apologies i actually needed you to see
that game because that's one of those things
that's going to eat at you for the rest of the
broadcast you you must have seen that game now
that you've looked at it i think it rings
about a distant bell i think probably my
coach showed it to me years ago but i will say
and i will confess it you know full disclosure
i'm not as well versed in some of sort of
the classics as some of my fellow gm's i
think i know a fair amount but but there's a
lot of games that i that i just haven't seen
and so i you know yeah you you've got 350 rating
points on me but i've got a decade or more of
just browsing chess books so and you've got
a lot of trivia under your belt as well just
going to brag on your behalf also dania i
was alive when informatory was a real thing
i mean i i i actually have some informator and um
i actually have this affinity for old school stuff
like that so i like flip phones and old books
and information so i do have that side of me
uh which which respects that kind of stuff
a lot you know i guess a nostalgia for it
so yeah in any case i think they might
still be making them i'm not sure
yeah i think that maybe they're digitized so
check out informator if you have that particular
passion and andrew is checking out that d3 pawn
so has this opening strategy backfired for nihal
his position is solid i don't see a way directly
to break through for andrew maybe activate this
rook via e6 but you also have to be careful maybe
just create some loft on the background with h6
because that could also come back to impact black
okay d e by by andrews he's opening up the file
i would say de should be the proper recapture for
niho i mean fe allows knight g4 that seems pretty
unthinkable is something bothering him though
yeah i mean you want to activate your rook
you want fewer pawn islands but the number
one reason is just like you said the g4 square
is a little bit too weak to allow knight to g4
that's right and there is an interesting
tactic where b5 knight c5 then you take
on g2 and by knight takes f3 swinging that
queen over to okay so he has taken but now
he has activated the rook via e6 of course a7
is still untouchable white's queen is tied down
to this f3 pawn and andrew swinging his rook
around probably to h6 but maybe also to f6
yeah i think it's a position where he's going
to keep toggling his rook to force white's
pawns to advance and then eventually the want the
pawns are going to be vulnerable so like rook h6
h4 rook g6 and then it's getting kind of hard to
push pawns because if you play g4 knight takes g4
almost certainly looks winning something like
that yeah exactly i'm just showing it on the board
white's whole position collapses black is more
than enough attackers and again we see 30 seconds
to 43 seconds it is going to be another scramble
and this is one of the worst kinds of positions
to play when you don't have much time remaining on
your clock i don't see off the top of my head mic
a way to to protect everything uh now knight takes
f3 here is actually possible and queen takes c5
that would be okay he goes for cup six and knife
d7 trying to root that knight out so what is what
if rook takes f3 though what if rook takes f3 i
guess he wants queenie two and now the rook is
kind of stranded i don't really believe in that
but will andrew find a refutation in time maybe
rook takes f3 knight g4 something crazy whoa this
is a very interesting idea by the whole andrew
could also go rook h6 here just kind of taking
a step back he's definitely trying to calculate
rook takes f3 but he's down to 10 seconds this is
going to be another time scramble squandering the
time advantage to try to find the knockout blow
but if you don't find it you've just burned up
80 percent of your time on this one he's got two
seconds he's gotta make a move rook age six so
he bails out knee-hill probably breathing a side
relief now oh and okay you could not have taken
on h2 there the king was escaping now it fizzles
out a little bit queen takes a7 is now possible
and the tables have turned andrew into a little
bit too much clock mike if you trade queens too
the white rooks make a lot more sense in the black
rooks because the attack just fizzled to nothing
exactly and now one pawn to the good and one
second friend if he is trying to unfortunately
trade a queen that's a great move that would
have been a great move but he goes after the
pawns andrew trying to rip open the king position
five seconds for nihal he is definitely not out of
the woods trying to trade queensland or refusing
of course a four maybe just start pushing the pawn
wreckage one stopping h4 all right what's going
on here queen e500 trying this way and that way
to get to white's position another time scramble
y'all activating his rook via c5 what a maneuver
oh he blunders his queen oh that works oh but okay
it was already lost i was going to suggest queen
d4 to trade queens but if you know your opponent's
gonna blunder the queen then clearly he knows more
than i do no that was that would have been a
great move and a bit of a heartbreaker there
mike for andrew who seemed to have that incredibly
strong attack going and just not quite enough time
to calculate the ramifications of rook takes
f3 so a very savvy choice by new hope to go 97
that was the turning point and the
score ladies and gentlemen is tight
second win in a row for knee hall and what we've
seen so far is having the better position is not
always worked out to victories uh these
couple positions were white where neal's
got the strong wedge pawn neither one is led to
victory andrew was better most that game this
reminds me of a very frustrating experience when
i was a kid playing mario kart where the number
two player always got the better weapons and
overtook the number one player on the final lap
so anyway smarter chess i'm not sure
what the predictions were for a mario
kart reference in the first hour oh but it's 101
where i'm sitting so i did not get the mario kart
reference in in the first hour i can't help
you that because i've never played mario kart
i was my my go-to game was age of empires that is
basically the only game i played and super smash
brothers on an old nintendo 98 with my brother
those were the only two games i played as a kid
well we're actually borrowing from video games on
my last chess kids show with national master alice
lee we did a speed run just like they try to do on
video games where you try to beat the video game
as quickly as possible alice and i did a speed
run to see who could beat all the bots the fastest
but actually our speed run was mostly who
could beat the most spots in 10 minutes
there's a problem with a speed run on the chess
kid bots you want to hear what the problem is
i do well during quarantine as you probably know
vishyanan was stuck in germany because of the
flight situation and was uh trying to play his son
on chess kid whose son was still in india and uh
that she talks to me on whatsapp and
he's like mike i've got this question um
how strong is bot level 10 on chess kid
and i said well vishy you know i can't
beat level 10 i assume it's an im or gm string
and vichy says to me mike i can't beat level 10.
i said okay maybe you made that bot too hard now
in fairness to vichy i don't think he was taking
it that seriously he did say if he focused really
hard he thinks he would have a good chance but um
but there you go bot level 10 i think it's called
uh it's called megahertz i have to remember what
our bots are called interesting well vishy can't
beat it then that's that's a pretty good indicator
even bishop not taking something seriously
is still fishy and what have i done admitting
that i never played mario kart i normally like
daniel's commentary but this is unbearable oh man
i have reached a point of no return mike i should
have never said that you know i can hang my queen
on analysis and they'll laugh and call the bow
test gambit we'll have a good time but you'll
never be forgiven if there's a piece of culture
that they've experienced that you haven't so
i was too busy playing a board game my apologies
yeah like don't tell anybody but i've never seen
lord of the rings and if people find out
about that then i'll never hear it we won't
even be able to go back to chess for the next
three hours are we still on air oh goodness i
think we might still be on air mike yes as ben we
are both going to be fired after this broadcast
is there a level of this microphone lower
than mute that's a ben feingold joke
that's funny yeah i think that also i i
had that element of russian upbringing so
some of the sort of stuff i did it was somewhat
unconventional um and some of the stuff i watched
as a kid i did love scooby-doo though that was
my so my school ended at three and i remember um
just running home and watching the reveal of the
monster at scooby-doo that was my moment of my day
i i can't add anything that conversation except
that um you'll always be an eight-year-old boy
to me don't you oh well that's very sweet i
don't think i can continue this broadcast i'm
getting emotional all right so knight
b6 now let's take a look at the game
we have a middle game on the board another
london where andrew has well a knight on b6
right in the sort of midst in the heartland
of black's position this knight on g5 though
it's in a little bit of trouble
although i guess it has the e4 square
in case of h6 now notice if black goes h6 he can
take on e6 and this knight on g6 is going to be
undefended so it's actually kind of annoying
andrew preparing to expand on the queens i
was super he is definitely better here i think he
has gotten sort of his type of position what niho
could consider is something like e5 at the right
moment maybe you break through in the center you
try to mix things up because again black is very
very crimped but mike we've seen nihal very very
sort of measured and good in these positions even
when it seems like his position is pretty cramped
yeah i mean but the goal remember donya
is to get the slightly worse position
i'm not sure that uh nihal's got the memo on that
yeah exactly the knight on b6 is one of those
funny pieces that's controlling a lot of squares
and as being an octopus but might never get out
right exactly um so it might you might as well
try to support it there now maybe one way that
uh andrew's trying to hedge his bets
when he does play c4 if neil takes
the knight does have this potential evacuation
route through a4 which i agree is not ideal but
as they say in russian this night is an eternal
night which kind of goes into what you're saying
mike it can't be chased it can't be won by a
pawn but it's kind of pretty much there forever
so nicole taking his time here this is an
important moment he could try to play knight t5
and trade off the knights that's one one option
um but andrew could follow up with c4 and that
knight could be replaced by upon ledge wait is
this this would be known as upon wedge right
or no well no because it's behind the
black pawn so it's a little bit obscure
you know ah so it's behind the bottom of
the five inches i think it doesn't count
as a wedge because it's not blocking a black
pawn which would really inhibit the space it's
it's on the other side so it's just it's strange
you know that it's like casting owen wilson in the
movie behind enemy lines it's just a strange
choice aha they're totally yes i've seen that
movie many times my favorite one willston see
when you say wilson the only association i make is
uh wilson in castaway that might have been
a few movies to make me cry i don't i'm not
usually i'm kind of get emotional while watching
a movie type kind of guy but that was that got
to me for sure well what about isolation when
you play these online matches do you like to
be in a house with nobody else so there's no
chance of like i i'll be honest with you when
i do broadcast i don't even want anybody around
me because just i want this feeling of like um
you know like this being my my inner quiet
place so i agree completely um and it's
it's the case for me when i do broadcast or when
i play tournaments um sort of i like to be fully
fully engaged but the first few times i played um
i played magnus uh in these long matches i was in
my dorm room's computer cluster with sort of my
friends just talking um and that can actually add
an element of sort of it can lighten the feeling
of playing a high stakes or high stress match
but i agree like when you're broadcasting you just
need to be fully fully engaged let me ask you when
you're in your dorm room and you're playing the
best player in the world do your friends have any
idea what's going on so how do you describe that
to them so the first time i got paired with magnus
um in in one of the titled arenas i i so i was
you know i was just sort of playing casually
and i was prepared to magnussen so i tell my my
friends okay guys you need to kind of quiet down
here playing magnus and of course they knew who
magnus is i mean they they've heard of magnus
they're not chess players but they don't fully
understand the magnitude get it magnus magnitude
of playing magnus so i was trying to kind of
not be obnoxious but i think it was very clear
to them that i had suddenly become 100 times more
intense um and eventually they kind of understood
um but yeah it was interesting the knight on
b6 does have a route back to the game but now
black is faced with the question of whether or
not to take and the classic question of the day
is it a strong pawn or is it a weak pawn my first
inclination is that it's quite weak right but it
could be used as a decoy and white could break
through in the center with something like d5
and if this happens well that f7 pawn is going
to be things can collapse here for black so the
problem might be not so much the pawn as the pawn
uses it so you could maybe take and go rookie 7
lending more support to the c6 one but
obviously now the spawn could become a strength
and the queen could swing around to a5 and a6 a6
is suddenly uh very very weak as well so this is
a a definite pickle for black if andrew does
not if niho does nothing then white could take
on t5 and ruin black's pawn structure h6 might
be considered here uh by knee hall but again
white could take on d5 simply drop his knife
back and guess what he's got a big positional
advantage here with this terrible bishop
facing the spawn double pawns in the center
so big time decision by neil i think andrew
is so far playing an excellent positional game
yeah and andrew has burned a lot of time as well
despite the fact that we generally regard him as
being a little bit of a faster player that that
lack of time will they cost him in the previous
game and it's the reason that this match is tied
he might have been able to hold that position
for it not for him being down
10 seconds in game number five
that's exactly right and dipping below 30
seconds now is knee hull so okay so h6 so
he's decided on this move chasing the night away
now again a decision trainer does he in fact
take on d5 and as you said mike i think he needs
to make these decisions a little bit faster go
with his gut his intuition is incredible and i can
just attest to that firsthand uh but we see him
burning through his time advantage here so he's
trying to do i take this knife maybe if bishop d5
nihal could actually take the knight in order to
preserve the integrity of his pawn structure more
or less in the center but again andrew could
go after that on an a6 let's see what is what
decision he makes he does go for bishop takes d5
and d-hall actually takes back with his bishop
so andrew could take and he has a stable advantage
here the pawn majority on the queen side but both
below 30 seconds this is going to be yet another
time scramble every single game mike has come down
to basically a time scramble fascinating stuff
yeah and the double pawns while they may look like
a weakness they actually deprive white's pieces of
a lot of entry squares so they're not fun to look
at but they do a great job of guarding a bunch
of squares in the e file that white's pieces
would like to use great point and it could also
be an anchor point for blackstroke to reach e4
okay so andrew has pushed his pawn to
b4 where it is now pressured by the rook
knee hall could bring his queen to b8 he
decides to bring his knight over to c6
as you say these double pawns they they're
restricting white somewhat and again is this
a strength or is it a weakness that pawn on
before now the subject of discussion queen
27 it seems like black is very solid here it's
not going to be easy to break through and or
definitely still with the advantage going after
this pawn rook b5 looks good for black here he's
got to make a move here we go five seconds queen
f593 would be a problem so he chooses e6 instead
but that allows rookie one with tempo interesting
decision and he does it he had knight 64 there
actually which would be an interesting tactic aha
so queen pressuring the knight on c2 now knight
takes a five point d5 he's gonna make a move two
seconds for any hall here we go attacking the
knight he's moving it around to b5 all right it's
reflexes o'clock let's see if andrew's older mouse
i think it it has on so many occasions he's
definitely still better pushing in the end game
bishop on f8 so passive that pawn on a6 now very
weak this is going to be so hard to defend he's
picking off the pawn 94 dropping the rook back to
c4 and slow rolling it now is andrew he does not
have to rush rook c6 a huge threat knee-high
going after the ball the only thing he can
do generating some counter play but will it be
enough i don't think so look at those passers
look at those snappers 86 the knight guards all
the squares on the 8th amazing needs and now it
gives itself away for the greater good this is
going to be unstoppable pawns for andrew and
nihal accepting the inevitable resigning amazing
performance there by andrew keeping the pressure
his foot on the gas pedal all the way basically
from start to finish wired to wire victory as he
jumps up on top by one point mike he managed the
end game well he puts to bed that two game mini
winning streak from nihal once again takes the
lead and i just want to check the match clock here
how much time is left in the five minute section a
little bit less than 20 minutes yeah it looks like
it so this will not be the final game we'll have
at least two more games in this section and uh
you know we sometimes play the hypothetical game
in these matches hypothetically would andrew like
to be tied at least tied after the five-minute
segment i have to think yes i think that andrew
is putting a little bit more of his hopes and his
stakes on the faster time he's playing just fine
in the five minute and despite the increment he he
wants you know he's looking for the bullet section
the increment does not fully as we have seen
counteract the effect of last time and uh i think
he might have that marginal edge in time scrambles
as we see nihal taking his time on move five
so yeah we see nihal taking his time here with
a kind of a lie that has become fashionable
recently mike it's almost like a queen's
indian defense in reverse or something
yeah and uh i've seen this hikaru is a big fan
of this system with white it can actually contain
some venom if black does not handle the central
tension properly that extra tempo as you say
could come in very handy i think andrew is doing
a good job of this now one example of this would
be if you just kind of take everything in a castle
and you're very casual well guess what white can
take on c6 take on g7 and then fork the king and
the pawn so this transformation could actually
be a little bit negative for black so andrew with
some important decisions here in the early going
i got to ask you saw that so quickly is that a
canned trap that you'd seen before did you just
figure that out so quickly i'm just like
there's no i'm not big on cam straps okay
okay um just that's i i hate canned traps as
much as i can tuna okay i don't like tuna so i
don't like traps but i've seen ideas like this
before and usually um a lot of people wonder
about this you know how do i see stuff quickly
a lot of it is pattern recognition i've seen
something similar right a similar fork even
though it's been wearing different clothes
so well let me ask another question in the early
moments of the game as we try to figure out where
the players are going to sort out their pieces i
think the first trivia question went well so let's
try another one of the 16 players in the chess.com
junior speed chess championship which one
has played in an official event on chess kid we
used to have an a chess kid national championship
it was called the chess kid online national
invitational championship that's a mess so
we called it conic but anyway which of the
16 players has played in the official flight
it was in the very fledgling days of jessica
there you see all the players on the screen
so you've got to pick one of them and i believe
this was back in 2013. so i'm going to follow
see who gets it right you'll get your name
announced on the air i don't know if i have
license to give away premium memberships but
i'll at least announce her name on the air
and i'm looking at the chess.com tv chat yes
but i won't say it until later yeah this one
you can use your powers of deduction have
a pretty good idea i actually don't know
i i mean it's just basically a wild guess but
that's really interesting and it's only been one
huh i think only one and we have a correct answer
from actually this is a person who often comes
to my chest kid live streams that's uh chitta
yang tiringari i'm sorry of course we already
have a famous membership so i apologize i botched
your name it's jeffrey xiong played back in 2013.
seems like just a moment ago but he was a kid
he's still a kid well you're still a kid compare
if you're talking to you know if your mom or
something but uh jeff is literally a kid back then
that is true wow how time flies mike i remember
jeffrey as a feed a master then an i am guess
what he's over 2 700 now all grown up well to
me i guess it all depends on your perspective
um and uh yeah i love those trivia questions
that's really interesting it's just so cool
to watch the progression of these young
players you know as they start out and then
they become stronger and stronger now you're just
a touch older than these players not too much but
would you say that the players were watching now
are the first generation where internet chess was
practically required to get better i don't know
if i'm phrasing this question the way i want to i
mean i know you must have played a ton of internet
chess but in the last five to eight years internet
chess has gotten so much bigger and you were
already a gm five years ago yeah i would say
that i i i think i see what you're saying um i and
i would say the answer is yes now in my generation
it was sort of split 50 50 between people who were
big on online chess when they were little growing
up i was one of those people i played you know
tons and tons basically since the time i was seven
but i know many quite a few grandmasters right
around my age who were just not that big on
online chess as well and the generation
coming after which is who we're watching now
virtually all of them have a very very deep
footprint on of online chess yeah i asked
all the players a couple of pre-event questions
and i did not ask the question what was the most
formative chess book you read you read growing
up because i think i might have gotten a lot of
kids to say they never really read a chess book
right that's very true and sometimes i actually
find it very hard to answer those questions and
i'm like put on the spot and i just for it's like
what's your favorite movie and then you forget
every single movie i've ever watched you know
what i'm saying but but you're right i mean it's
it's not that kids don't read chess books but
there's just so many resources now that there's
various paths to take uh for improvement and um
yeah it'll definitely be interesting to explore
uh their their training routines and how they've
reached the top but just taking a look at the
game we see andrew's clock very very concerning
50 seconds after 14 moves i mean this is a
massively lopsided time situation now i don't
think black is worse here andrew trying to put
pressure on that on d4 the only issue is that
bishop on e4 really has no way no way back right
nihil could even consider something like knight h2
and he will be threatening to trap the bishop and
so does black need to play g6 in an emergency g5
sorry to get the [ __ ] i think he might but that
creates its own weaknesses on the king's side but
i think that's inevitable the knight can then
swing around to you i think quite like the smoke
i i said it more as an illustrative kind of
move but i actually the more i think about it
knight h2 makes some sense so we'll
see what he what he does he has time
to bernie has two minutes still extra he
can also yeah and he does it okay i like it
so does andrew now have to play g5 or does he what
he can do also is to take and something like 97
and get the bishop to c6 but that
involves seeing the center he does go g5
and knight f1 so knee hall oh look where he's
heading he's heading right for that h5 squad
juicy outpost there definite advantage here really
nice idea how the knight backs up to induce g5 and
then backs up again to head for h5 you don't see
that kind of idea very often indeed and the knight
moves backwards always produce that positive
aesthetic effect now nihal is spoiled for choice
he could take on d5 go bishop f3 and open up some
pressure on this pawn every move would involve
definitely knight h5 man i cannot draw arrows
today it's actually one of my weaknesses i'm so
sloppy at drawing arrows but you can also go c5
locking up the center and also going knight h5
so again it's one of those things where he's got
to make a decision relatively quickly to preserve
i would say a decently sized time advantage now
very quickly before we resume our discussion
we want to remind everyone that the
counter refers only to the five plus one
segment not to the whole match so after the ten
remaining minutes of the five minute portion the
counter will reset and there will be 60 minutes
of three plus one followed by 30 minutes of bullet
and uh dania we're showing this intricate
positional idea you failed to plug your book
i know you read it a long time ago but we were
just talking about books and you didn't even
remind people that you wrote a chess book about
positional chess when you were 14 years old right
uh i did i did and i um well it was it was
a great experience i certainly it's not one
of those things i don't recommend it to my
students even when i think they should work
on their positional chess i think there
have been a lot of better books written
on positional chess and i truly believe that but
you know the book really was a formative moment
in my chess development because i personally learn
really well when i write stuff down um i think
everybody has their way of learning and so the
book started out as a way for myself to improve
uh my positional understanding and it eventually
blossoms and neha well he is showing some
incredible positional understanding here look at
this i mean this black's position is collapsing
your f6 rookie six but is that sufficient
mike did i is that called plugging my book
uh well i don't know if it's still in print if
it's not still in print maybe you shouldn't be
plugging it but it is it is it is and and it's
so awesome to me that this entire attack was
born out of a retreat movement h2 exactly and
look at where it is now i mean speaking i mean
black king is going to be out of prince so now
upon to the good for new hall he can just take
another one i completely agree mike everything
started with that knight tour at age five
and now look what it is now two pawns extra
and attacking e-holes should take this home
queen up four to be considered now the saving
grace for tang is that he might run out of time
before he has to keep defending this position that
might put him out of his misery and if sauron wins
nihal wins we'll be back to three uh and a half
wins a piece with one game to go probably one game
but probably the way the
games have gone probably won
i wouldn't bury andrew quite you know one i think
to consider bishop b2 maybe and and rerouting the
bishop in the spirit of what nihal has that
he just decides to drop his knight back and
retool his pieces he's two puns two pawns extra
so it's not like he needs to deliver chuck knight
he's sort of casually improving his position now
andrew going for g5 so he is not going to go down
without a fight here yeah i sometimes don't try
to win these positions too quickly online because
you want to give yourself two ways to
win one on the clock and one on the board
you don't want to like go for the gusto if
you're risking anything and whoa you've got
to be careful now because queen f3 there's rook f6
that almost drops the queen but knight f5 i guess
i'm pretty sure he missed that but fortunately
as bishop f5 and again that knight the hero of
the position andrew trying to find chances here
bishop h4 he's putting pressure on that this is
a little bit concerning for nihal but he can
just take the bishop on g6 and swing the queen
to d3 so i think he's fine but now 12 seconds
he has got to be careful in his own right this
would be a heartbreaker if he lets it slip andrew
won one of the pawns back definitely lost some
of the advantage but now the bishop coming to f4
bishop definitely wants to be on e5 might go there
right now we'll see but it's i mean rook f1 he's
keeping one pair of rooks to preserve the attack
andrew has done a tremendous job you're generating
defensive chances nihal's still better but solid
solid position and he's trading now he can take
on g3 i think that much of the advantage has
evaporated he has still off upon if it takes on
d5 though wow okay now chances for andrew queen b1
possible knee hill trying to push his pawn
dropping his request for the defense four seconds
now another time scramble another time scramble
and he can force a draw play rook g6 rook h6 he
might i think that's what he's going for but knee
hold counter attack the pawn there's no defense
aha f6 now if you take queen h7 between h7 he's
gonna make a move one second get it will it be
made he did we'd have five they're both attacking
is it made who's all the results possible and
andrew loses that time that is lost he cannot move
the screen without giving up the rook wow but so
close game andrew but did not quite manage and
kudos to nihal they're incredible yeah i think
if we had our eval bar working then we would
have broken it during that final time scramble
it probably was bouncing up and down faster than
the stock market the last couple days so exactly
wow and um amazing job by andrew their generating
chances but nihal even in time pressure kept that
foot on the gas pedal kept generating chances and
what a win in our match is tied this is almost
definitely going to be the last game of the five
minute portion score is three and a half three and
a half incredible welcome to the 6 400 viewers
or so this is the opening round of the 2020
junior speed chess championship sponsored by
chesskid.com you could call these kid chess kids
although they can all um you know hang with
the world's elite at this point they're all
uh unbelievably awesome grand masters and
we're we're watching the number one seed
nihal star who's got his hands full against
the number 16 seed andrew tang of minnesota
the qualifier however he's fully worthy of being
in this event absolutely 16c in name only and uh
a player whose reputation precedes him as both a
very strong grandmaster and a legend of blitz and
bullet so indeed nihal does have his hands
full we we see here a london defense where
andrew has snagged a pawn i'm pretty sure this
is some sort of theoretical line it doesn't seem
to inspire confidence now what nehal could be
going for is some sort of lead in development
uh and maybe he will target this v-pawn now
andrew could just drop his queen back to a4
i feel like this isn't great for black eye maybe
i'm missing i mean nowadays mike some of these
lines for to a human eye they might seem you know
like winning but but there's subtleties in the
position that they give full-fledged counterplay
to the opposition yeah in the last game the black
bishops were always side by side now they're side
by side again in fact don you might remember in
the last game the black bishops were on h7 and
h8 and then they magically got to g5 and g6 it's
like they both move like knights indeed when
i wasn't watching they both made the l shape
but yeah the compensation here for the
pawn looks i don't know if it's enough but
i'm sure that nihal must have had this on his
computer and the computer said it was okay to play
right but that could also be risky and
i've definitely had experiences with that
where you check the evaluation it says equal
then you look at the position why is it equal
again and it can be very hard to just demonstrate
but queen v8 might kneel incredibly strong move
this is a fork and a very deadly one if you
defend the e5 pawn not only does black 1v2
but the rook is trapped so andrew might have to
give up the e5 but that is a heck of an important
one not only does he give up the pawn he might
have to move his own king out and his king will
be quite a bit more unsafe than blacks nihal
could follow it up with rook b8 so has andrew
blundered with queen c5 is the question i think
he has yeah usually try to figure out which pawn
to give back and still get a playable position but
as you just pointed out it could be that neither
one gives you a playable position and there's no
counter attack on the black king because famously
knight guard kings from queens quite well we've
seen it a million times and um there's no way that
white can generate anything against the black
king even though the black king can't castle
that's right and the queen before the more
i look at this might be the lesser evil
and then going for this position now the bishop
will be hanging in that case which i missed
initially now he goes like okay so queen takes e5
is not he has queen e3 fortunately so knight d2 i
actually really like in the event of queen takes
b2 you're gonna have rook b1 and that black has
got to be careful because rook b7 even immediately
becomes a very real possibility that 281 track
could be met with knight b1 and really it's
anyone's game this could get very very tactical so
we can take c5 definitely the safer option queen
takes b2 seems a little bit too speculative for me
i gotta be honest with you second straight time
we've had a london actually third straight time
we've had a london but they've all been exciting
london so indeed don't don't believe the uh the
wrap on the london system now if we see a berlin
i'm going to say i'm going to cry foul i'm going
to say that i'm leaving the comments here if you
see but i don't think either of these pledged i
mean andrew is not you can count on one hand the
amount of times andrew has gotten e1 e4 although
he's been doing it more recently in bullet uh
so we'll see wait if you're saying it's in your
contract you can leave the commentary when there's
a berlin i thought it was a contract no it's in
mike i specifically bargained for that clause okay
just good to know the producer yeah no i bargained
for it and they wouldn't budge but you know
then i called up some people i was like you know
i cannot look at the berlin anymore and
you're you're doing this so i'm not gonna
be a commentator but here we have a not a berlin
game but an end game and an unbalanced one as he
said mike um i actually don't know if it looks it
looks good for black right because of the visual
deficiency and white's pawn structure i do think
white's position is still solid this knight on
b3 does have a strong hold on c5 one idea for
black though skoroxie ca in the 95 and mount
pressure on this backwards c3 pawn and he does go
95 first if the bishops are traded i'll also point
out the knight is an outpost on c4 so problems to
solve here for sure for andrew yeah i was thinking
about this exchange though you get the c4 square
for your knight but the white knight gets to c5
somehow it feels to me that that's a net win
for white because then the c3 pawn although it's
backward will never be attacked because there's
too many knights clogging up to c file so i was
wondering if you got white to play knight c5 if
you induced it somehow if you would just put a
rook on the c file and play knight d7 or something
and play without the knights yeah that's actually
quite interesting and i've seen a lot of model
games where that happens you know they say rook
end games are drawn but when you have a weakness
like that it can be hard to defend in the long
term so we do it and andrew's got to decide yeah
basically where he puts his knight you could also
put it on d4 there we go a solid square but one
where it could potentially be chased away by e5
and don't forget after the five minute ends this
should be the final five minute game we have 60
minutes of three minute action and then 30 minutes
of bullet action all with a one second increment
and this is the final 90 minute game so if any
anybody wins this one they will take a small lead
into the break now do you put a lot of stock
into that final game of each segment do you
think that creates a psychological effect
um that spills over into the next segment
i think kind of when it's back and forth
yeah because your only chance to sort of sit
and dwell and really take stock of what's happened
is these two pretty short breaks that we've got
so um otherwise you don't have time to dwell on
wins and losses i mean you know better you've
played what a dozen of these matches this summer
but i do take stock in it actually i personally it
would affect me is all i can say i don't know the
inside workings of these players brains and i'm
not a sports psychologist but um how about you i
mean you had a similar match structure and you're
yeah i mean it's it's the thing is you know that
break it can definitely do you good or it could do
you harm and when you lose you dwell in that last
game you dwell on the fact that you had a lead it
did um so i also think it's very psychologically
important now both of these players we know are
virtually unshakable so in this particular match
i think it's largely minimized uh but still one
cannot deny that this is an important game and
it is officially the last game of the segment
as andrew now is it a problem with my connect okay
it seems that he has disconnected or is this on my
end i'm afraid i see a red bar here uh a4 was
played rook ac8 and then i don't see uh rugby
c8 and then i don't see anything happening okay
three definitely the move but i'm a little bit
concerned about android's internet here as on my
end it shows a red bar my end too and while andrew
is sorting this out we can take a look at how the
live odds have changed let's go ahead and pick up
pick up our our stock market tracker there we
see the nasdaq outpacing this no just kidding
the bobble head of knee hall has inched back up
suggesting that uh that it's just fine for him
to go into the three-minute segment with around
an even score i i find that quite interesting
yeah i think neither neither player is
particularly against that you know andrew
says i'm going to keep it close until
the bullet hole says okay you know um
i i stabilize things i play decently i'm also
very fast so both players are satisfied okay
it seems that the situation has been
fixed and andrew indeed goes rook a3
so nihal really laying it on here the pressure
is quite severe but you know the principle of two
weaknesses might come into play which basically
says in order to win one of these end games
you one weakness is not enough because the
opponent can direct all of his defensive power
to defending that weakness as we see here this
pawn on c3 for the moment safely defended andrew
getting his bishop out and chasing the rook away
this could turn if nihal is not careful andrew
does have some potential with his pieces knight
could come to b5 although not immediately and
he does have upon majority which you could start
pushing again you've got to be careful because b5
runs into a fork so you have to do it in a very
measured fashion let's see how andrew plays this
the fascinating thing i find about these end games
is you're always trying to figure out who benefits
from a knight exchange who benefits from a bishop
exchange who benefits from a knight versus bishop
exchange because those seem to be a lot of the
key questions here the four different kinds of
end games you could have if you reduce down to
one minor piece for each side right and i think
it's actually very unclear if you go knight c4
check who benefits from this because black does
develop the potential of going e5 and chasing
the night away but but in closed positions like
these we know how scary knights can be the
knight could pretend and he does go knight
c4 he takes it to the pawn so he's preparing for
e5 in which case the d file is going to be open
notice that if android goes v5 and knight c6 check
that rook on b2 is hanging so that doesn't work
the knight just doesn't quite have time but he
could go b5 and b6 that does look very speculative
though he drops his king back to e1 bracing for
impact here so that a rook move to the d-file
is not checked i think a great decision by nihal
here the opening of the default benefits him the
bishop has an outpost on d3 but again will it be
enough will he actually be able to break through
because for the time being he also has to keep
an eye on the possibility of going b5 and p6
he cannot get too crazy um and divert all of
his resources toward pressuring white on the d
file well shouldn't nihal play a6 here because
if you stop the a and the b pawns from moving
then the white rooks don't look too useful on the
a and the b files i think he did something similar
by going bishop b8 now the bishop is supervising
that diagonal rook d3 is to be considered here
um sort of a very typical move you and he takes on
d2 so he trades one pair of rooks but i'm not sure
that that is really the patchwork getting a
significant advantage i think andrew is bringing
a sigh of relief here again that knight moved
backwards the knight heading for g3 potentially
i don't think nield is worse but i don't see a
clear way for him to break through he's maybe
trying to do something with f5 and g5 i don't know
how scary that is andrew look at his knight hither
and dither to f3 it goes nihil stopping it from
coming to g5 and now biting his time to sandra
no definitely nihal still pressuring he's trying
to make something happen pushing his pawns now
knight two is attacking upon defending it
king e2 andrew shifting his king rook to
d now the rook could head to d3 yep it's going
brilliant play here by niho look at him on all
sides of the board he is pushing it in and he
can't take on c4 because the bishop should be
five what a trap andrew repairing it repeating
the position again a time scramble yeah i think
black's gonna be able to move his king to
d5 and then maybe play pawn f4 at some point
i like that idea as well he goes
h4 comes at it from the other side
of course andrew doesn't react driving it
to h3 creating a potential weakness on h2
e4 engine trying but f4 that was that was a bit
of a hasty decision now things are looking very
very grim that pawn 94 is very weak nihal could
attack with ic6 defending it is andrew fg though
whoa i think he could have played rook takes d2
f takes and then the pawn on h4 h3 goes free he
could have an fgh that was a great catch mic but
now andrew pushing his pawn this is not over yet
he's got to take but how do you stop the pawn
rook b8 okay some active counter play for andrew
but will it be enough i don't believe it will
e4 rook c5 the rook c5 oh my goodness have the
tables turned yeah and the black pawns are stein
look at this look at this this is incredible mike
your move was probably the cleanest uh shot
that knee hall had and now it might be a draw
amazing now the a pawn is still quite annoying
uh you're guarding the a6 square so the white
rook has trouble getting behind it although
there are some ways that's right who is better
here definitely knee hall still pushing this
is practically speaking very hard to defend
with such a bad one you can take on e4 this
might fizzle out rook b4 rook before wow it
still not that easy but it's still not easy
time to watch the josh fidel video on chess.com
fill the industry standard on queen versus rush
wow now does white have a fortress usually the way
this is one mic i think is some sort of zug's lawn
forcing the king to disattach itself from the pawn
but it's not easy yeah whenever the pawns forward
you can come at the king from behind the h-pawn i
think you just assume is not there that can be won
easily so right i'm not in my table base right now
but i do believe it's probably a win don't ask me
how to do it josh where are you yeah hey josh and
he's trying he's using the queen quirks screwing
the queen around now he's shifting the king
it's so hard to find in two seconds you can also
blunder mate here i mean you can plunder the queen
you can mouse slip this is i mean black's not
out of the woods he's trying this way that way
will he get the king out of the range of the pawn
he does decide to take h2 again as you said mike
that's not the important part though can you get
to the spawn on f5 queen takes h2 was on move 99
so who's on the count to move 149. oh my lens that
is i mean he left he's going to make 50 moves here
he's gonna try every which way at some point you
could try to move the king to h4 cause some sort
of zoom zone he's done it but andrew does have an
abundance of extra moves how do you make progress
king being on a more useful square but it's right
funny how white is never blocking with his rook
on e6 because it's more useful to keep the black
king stuck to the h file exactly that's a great
point as as long as the king is cut off queen
d5 though this could be zuma's long but rook
g5 that is an extra move for andrew rookie six
he's done it now that is progress for knee hall
if he can get a sting to d5 he does now is it
going to be still easy to win because rook against
queen is not easy to win look at this expert play
by knee he gets his king into g5 he's going to win
the pawn out he's going to win the pawn and this
is looking grim 30 moves remaining as i go grab my
john nunn book on the shelf oh it's too far away
continuing how about my barrett's game manual
he's now he's made a lot of progress it
looks like he's going to win the spawn he is
and defending this with three seconds mike a
computer can actually do a great job of defending
this but in a time scramble it's virtually
impossible to defend it as resiliently as possible
the only trick here mike is some sort of stalemate
trapper the rook gives itself away anyhow we'll
have to watch that but he is making plenty of
progress king six wins wow yeah this is actually a
computer workout on chess kid i have trouble being
the computer queen versus rook and he's still got
about 42 moves remaining before any kind of 50
move rule there's a key position in the second
defense where you try to uh you have to actually
lose a tempo by triangulating your queen right
but actually andrew is doing a good job he's
managed to bring his king back this might be
the content and now i know i think you stair step
your queen down the a and the b files right and
fork the rook and he's done it quinn a one queen
b1 amazing in time pressure finding it very nice
catch mike and this is game over and what a
herculean effort 145 moves by knee hill jumping
out on top four and a half three and a half as
the five minute section concludes amazing stuff
from niholsarin and hats off to andrew for an
incredibly resilient defense as well might be the
longest five minute stretch in history because
that last game overstepped the the five minute
section by so much but amazing 145 moves and if
there is a psychological advantage conferred by
going into the break where they win it's probably
multiplied by that grind by the fact that you
did convert such a difficult ending so four and a
half to three and a half small lead for the number
one seed but this this is this is virginia umbc
actually it's not is umbc beat virginia by like
20 points in that game but this is the closest one
versus 16 match up perhaps in chess.com history
and we expected action we got action and
guess what there's a lot more excitement ahead
as we will soon after a quick break begin the
three-minute portion only a one-point lead by niho
amazing five-minute section here and we will
let the players catch their breasts we will
catch our own and we will be back shortly
with 60 minutes of the three-minute portion
so
welcome back ladies and gentlemen to the
junior speed chess championship sponsored by
chess kid it is my pleasure to be commentating
along with video master mike line and we have
the three minute portion coming right your
way but first a couple of clarifications and
notes first and foremost the smarter chess
match prediction um mike talk us through
what you see here and has it aged well
in the context of the five minute portion
pretty close i mean i don't think we got there in
a way that many people would have thought we would
have gotten there which was andrew being ahead
or at least equal for most of the five one in
fact the only lead that i believe nihal has had is
through 145 move final game so nihal was favored
he was favored by two points he ended up
only winning this section by one point
um so he's still in the driver's seat and
you can see he's a favorite in every section
and if we look at the graph of the odds to win
he's actually it looks like a little bit higher
than when the event began even though he only
won that segment by one point um anyway wait
he's creeping up he's creeping up to back where
he was pre-event so uh i don't know i'm a little
bit surprised by that because if andrew goes into
the bullet down one i find it hard to make andrew
the underdog and right now there's no reason to
believe that andrew is going to go into the bullet
with any kind of sizeable deficit the way he's
playing no absolutely they're so evenly matched
and we just see every single game going into a
time scramble so to be honest with you mike i
you know i like the concept of these predictions
but we've seen time and time again it's just it's
so hard to make anything of it it could swing
either way the pendulum swings back and forth
and we're sure to see some more um amazing
time scribbles in the three-minute portion so
if you're planning on going anywhere um you know
not that there's anything else going on you're
definitely staying here because this is about to
get really fascinating and we have liftoff here
with another one of these ready sort of english
you know kind of openings yeah every openings had
the word ish at the end of it because they've
been more about setups than real openings so
um 73 chance for knee hall to win but 100
chance that we're going to have some fun
and we're going to learn something the
big question is when do i switch over
from my chess kid hat to my to my chest.com hat
so whose hat am i wearing for this segment you
want to go chest back i like both of you mike
i look good i'm going to go chest.com but maybe
we'll switch back to chess kid if i'm feeling
quite juvenile later on and here we have that
e3 g3 setup which i have marked down as being
the same as game five which nihal won that game
i don't think he won because of this setup but he
did win the game nonetheless right and he decides
to repeat it we've seen the players being pretty
principled here both kind of drifting nihal has
had a little bit more variation in his play than
andrew but they're both drifting to sort of the
same set of setups with andrew of course playing
as usual his classical repertoire sticking to the
same openings uh but again the whole taking the
first sort of long think uh and he decides to
release the central tension with dc we get this
sort of hanging pawn structure here with the c5
and d5 pawn sort of both being isolated now the
rook lifting itself i think to d2 in order to
put pressure which andrew curtails with knight e4
but he takes the foot off of the defense of the d5
one thing to consider for knee haul here you could
try to trade knights with knight c3 and um sort of
clear the path in preparation for putting pressure
on this d5 and we'll see what he does he's done a
different version of the same thing maybe in order
to open up the bishop's influence in the d5 pawn
and although donya is horrible at plugging his
own book i am going to plug my own website um
we have all of our lessons structured in order on
chess kid and king level 92 is all about hanging
pawns and if there's one idea i stressed in that
video is you want the hanging pawns you want one
of the two to move because then that releases
the ability for them to control the other square
and when you blockade the hanging pawns they're
much more effectively targeted they're wearing
cement boots as we would say in chess kid land
so in many of the examples i showed you want
one of the two pawns to move then they get stuck
and then you're able to gobble them up so king
level 92 if you have no idea what i'm talking
about go to chesskid.com lessons and you'll see
what all the kids know about which is all these
great lessons on just kid absolutely and i agree
that i'm terrible at plugging my own stuff but
i am good at plugging other people's stuff and i
do regularly recommend chess kid material to my
students um it's awesome stuff so you know if
you're here to get better it's amazing content and
a lot of it on different topics so i can throw my
voice behind that as well mike um you're doing
some awesome stuff and need hall seems to be
doing some awesome stuff with those hanging
pawns as he has gotten rid of andrew's dark
squared bishop now the knight on c4 is now hanging
because the bishop on b7 is protected uh but where
will it go will it go to e5 or will it go to
e3 now one thing to calculate after knight e3
notice that the queen is pinned
bishop takes d4 seems to be possible
it's it's complicated though he does go knight
e3 now andrew with a big choice on his hands
does he go d4 and seek some sort of complications
i don't see a response the bishop takes d4 or
does he go something like rook cd8 trying to
spring an x-ray and after the capture is maybe
knight b6 but here you have to pay attention to
this bond something like queen g4 could strike
out of the blue liberating the queen from the
pin and threatening checkmate a lot of things
to calculate here as both sides now have used
more than half of their time in andrew going for
the latter defending the pawn yeah and by the way
if black if black had played knight b6 to defend
maybe white would have played b4 inducing c4
and then we get what i talked about which is
that you fix the pawns on one color and then they
permanently can't move and they become targets
and so andrew trying to avoid that with knight b6
but the queen is a little bit overloaded here it
is pinned a and b it is guarding the f6 knight if
it leaves and you have to take on f6 with a pawn
that would be a total disaster given that this
knight on e3 can jump to that f5 square knife f5
as uh grandmaster feinbuild likes to say bishop
e5 also to be considered here just driving this
bishop onto the outpost again we have a situation
where there's a lot of uh promising options
and it's so tempting to sink into a thought
and then you know have five seconds by the
end of your decision uh so neha will have to
find it in himself to follow his intuition um
already 38 seconds time flies so quickly when
you're making one of these decisions and it's easy
mike to be unsatisfied with every choice because
you're looking for a knockout yeah hanging pawns
notoriously difficult but my bird's eye view or
as millennials would say a drone's eye view they
look weaker than strong and in fact they do get
captured in fact daniel i would say the transition
to three-minute stuff because when you're playing
five minutes for an hour and a half you just you
you fall into a pace and you have to remind
yourself especially in that first game hey i
can't take 90 seconds on a move like i was able to
in the opening segment exactly it sounds trivial
but it's not it's just so hard to mentally adjust
um and there's that cool concept in psychology
i think it's called like perseveration where you
know if you move to the same to a different floor
in your apartment building first couple of times
you're gonna hit the button of that old floor in
your elevator so like your brain literally makes
that connection uh to whatever you're familiar
to obviously it's on a lesser scale here but it
does exist now we see nihal has gone for the sort
of materialistic approach he's one upon but now
andrew has sort of gotten rid of the tension in
the center he's traded some pieces and he's going
to go after the c4 pawn it's going to be lost
what does knee haul do here how does
he squeeze the most out of the position
obviously andrew should not take the queen then
the pawn is going to come to b3 and defend c4 but
which piece does he take c4 with this is
going to be in a very unpleasant end game
either way and we see nihal activating his
other rook he can trade one pair of rooks
he can also swing it to a5 and target the
a6 pawn tanya would rather have the extra
pawn which may or may not be used for would you
rather have the extra 20 seconds on your clock
definitely the extra pawn because this end game is
so easy to play nihal could make a lot of sort of
waiting moves and gain a little bit
of time out of stock we see here he is
getting right to business he's trading his
double pawn andrew activating his pieces which
is what he should do he might be going after
the pawn 92 this is going to be hard to win
uh mike especially with 13 seconds what niho is
trying to do is if brooke a1 he's going to go
rook c7 and double rooks on that defile so andrew
has to reckon with that as well he might have to
keep one of his rooks for defensive purposes on e7
which is what he does with rookie seven here we go
okay and black is not wanting to allow that
obviously that takes into account a lot of losing
possibilities by allowing the the double pac man
on the seventh rank definitely these end games can
be lost um if you if you over press and we see
nihal continuing to chip away at andrew's kings
side andrew going for the rook trade actually
that's a great move forcing the rook trade and
this definitely seems draws right because the
rook on a4 is very active it is holding down the
rook on d2 still attempts by nihol he can try to
bring his king over to the other side of the board
in order to free up his rook which is exactly
what he's doing andrew is following suit we see
the canon mouse game in action here under 10
seconds for both of them another time scramble
this is going to be definitely hard to
defend objectively though i think it's a draw
yeah there was a moment after king f5 that black
allowed rook d5 it's not that danya missed it
it's just that it would have lost the a pawn and
then if you put every pawn on the same side of the
board the winning chances go from two percent
to to nil and here we see enter continuing to
activate a species rook from f3 to a3 swinging
around uh multitasking holding down the rook
uh on the second rank the active pieces are
everything in an end game like this i don't see
a way for nihal to make much progress he's trying
to induce zouzovak f4 can be considered by andrew
the rook on f3 not only is it holding down
white's rook it's also cutting off white's king
and that is what seems to be the drawing factor
nihal continuing to make attempts what he could
have done is potentially swung the rook to f4
but that could be losing that's upon race and
let's see what he comes up with here it might he
might be succumbing to the inevitable and we have
a draw by repetition great save by andrew that
looked very concerning in the middle game but that
decision to give away upon was actually a very
savvy one as the end game gave him more chances
our first draw since the opening match we had
seven straight consecutive wins by one player
you don't see that very often but that just
goes to show that there's been neither player
has been willing to to settle for equality or to
trade down to a boring end game as either color
and we see another one of these interesting nimzo
indian lines where the queen is on d5 obviously
not hanging because of the pin uh but yeah it's
been incredibly combative um and just it's been
so close every single game just comes down to
the wire and we have every reason to believe
that it will continue to do so okay so penguin now
thinking what does he do with the central tension
does he go knight f3 does he take on c5 he decides
to go bishop d2 forcing the trade and we have
mass trades here this looks pretty good for
black though i think he's definitely equalized
despite white's two bishops there's one c3
though that's a pretty big asset for white
now explain because i'm literally not asking this
to set you up i'm actually asking this based on
my own knowledge okay to set me up white's got
the bishop pair the probably the easiest access
to the d file the black bishop on c8 is gonna
have to find a way into the game although i
realize b7 looks reasonable so why do you say
that black is fine when it seems like white's
got a lot of mini advantages because of the
possibility of going e5 right i think that
in a lack of targets and black's position a lot of
times visually the position might seem better and
i think white has a small pull but notice that
black has no targets in his position to attack
so it might be a little bit passive but if
you can just weather the immediate storm
um you'll eventually have a chance to develop
your pieces maybe take on e5 and go bishop d7
and i think you know 50 years ago or so people
wouldn't go into such a position but nowadays
with computers with increased defensive
capabilities players have realized that
these types of positions are actually tremendously
solid and they regularly go into them as black
with that being said i'm not denying that i
think white is definitely pressing here i like
andrew's position but i think nihal can make a
couple of accurate moves here maybe bishop d7
maybe take on e5 and then go bishop d7
and i think he should be able to hold
all right well computers making their
mark on chess and donya doing well
notice no evaluation bar is really needed this
position is more about feel and often you know
i have this problem especially in my kids
streams we don't use an evaluation bar but
there's a couple mistakes that a lot of viewers
make not just kids they see the evaluation go from
1.5 to 1.3 and they're like oh white white's blown
the advantage even though that's imperceptible
there's no grandmaster in the world that thinks ah
you know i'm probably up 1.5 no i'm up 1.3 that's
just not how humans think and there's also some
positions that frankly computers do not understand
um they think that in opposite colored bishop end
games that one site can be winning when any 1200
can look at it and say the extra pawn is worthless
and i could go on and on about these sorts of
examples um so no evaluation bar today but none
needed we've got one of the top american players
dania naredinsky and i'm just here for trivia i
know my place uh and in fact it's time for trivia
we've been talking about books today absolutely
this trivia question is brought to you by gregory
kaidanoff and he said name a 2700 who has never
read a book now i realize the younger generation
that may count for a lot of players so here's
the stipulation i'm requiring that you pick a
player above the age of 40. that's what makes it a
surprising ah okay a former 2700 or a current one
former so don't pick a niche geary because
he's not over the age of 40. anisha if you're
listening hi um and don't pick a player who's
only gotten to 2500. now this is incredibly hard
i would guess if you get this right i will give
you all of my wages for this commentary can i make
a guess or should i let the ch i should probably
let the chat think about this you can let the chat
yeah let's give the chat a minute let's go back to
the game and how about well we'll make uh the end
of this game is when i'll give away the answer so
we'll do a regular commentary and that'll give the
chat about three minutes to plug in their answer
pretty good well that's a fascinating question and
let's uh check back into this end game as we
see symmetrical piece uh balance here with night
bishop and rook inside bishop north now still
andrew we see knights both knights being attacked
if fva b and it seems like black's double pawns
are more accessible than whites so for that reason
he helped dropping his knight back to d5 still a
pull i think for um for andrew here especially if
you can get through the rook to c1 first bishop
d7 could also be met with knight c5 hitting the
bishop and drawing it back to c8 uh so still we
see these problems facing nihal but 36 seconds to
a minute and 15 that's a pretty significant time
advantage nihal has time to find a way out of this
i still think he should be equalizing maybe king
f7 and try to get the king into e7 but if rook c1
what can happen is e4 forcing the knight back
and then a penetration to c7 could happen
that could be a very much unwelcome sight for
black let's see how nihil solves these problems
i can tell you i won a lot of games as
a junior by anticipating the end game
and already having my king ready now it's well
known that once the end game happens you should
march your king to an active spot but white is
almost sneakily getting the king to an active spot
before some trades happen unfortunately even if
i picture a chess position here with no pieces
except the kings there's not a lot that the white
king can target uh that's the sort of downfall
of the king activity that's exactly right and and
that's sort of the theme right the lack of targets
he does decide on king f7 now my question is
what does he want to do here against this idea
of e4 which could be very unpleasant now you could
allow the rook infiltration to the seventh ring
and try to bring it back out with king d8 but i
mean as they say that's a little bit manga s so
i think we'll see e4 or bishop f3 is also good
because if you take it there we go because if you
take on g5 he brings his king in but now this
pawn is a little bit we finally have a target
the question will it be enough um sufficient
fodder for a winning attempt by andrew i
don't think so because this king extremely well
placed mike to lend enough support to this point
yeah but still you i don't know i like this for
white a lot your king can march to d4 or your
knight can sit there forever it seems like the
kind of position you can torch your opponent but
torture does not always mean a full point yeah
i think there are certain soviet chess players
who would salivate at the possibility of position
like this but e4 wait a minute e4 looks c so if
he four works c5 takes if you take back there's a
fork because of the pin right did he blunder oh i
think that was a big chance my andrew there mike
i'm not sure that was anticipated by neil but he
decides to keep the torture going as you say this
is one of those positions you can make a million
moves here i agree i think that white's got the
practical chances i think nihal should be holding
this if he's careful but four seconds on the
clock it is so easy to blunder or allow something
yeah and uh nihal just got done torturing in the
final five minute game in that queen versus rook
and looks like the torturer is going to become the
torturee i'm not sure those are words but we're
making stuff up here um i'm you know i i went to
a liberal arts college i'm supposed to know this
stuff but i don't know so am i and i don't either
so we're in the same boat here okay mike uh don't
don't sleep on the kingside pawns actually
those could become targets at one point too
and look at him swinging the rook
around and maybe bring the king to d4
and you gotta be careful you can get checkmated
on c4 and b4 is a very committal move because
you're allowing the rook potentially to come
to c4 g5 here we go now has andrew over pressed
after bishop a4 he's got to be very careful that
other flank could cost him bishop a4 now that
we're coming to c2 i think he's got a little bit
wrong he's making space for the rook to come to g2
oh but now bishop d1 is a threat if the rook
moves okay dropping his knight back to f5 king
e5 centralizing king g4 what's going on here
bishop d7 i think black is better rook c2 he's
taking a pawn like a self-made puzzle happening
here wow now look at look at black stroke there's
a pawn majority andrew has left this out of
control completely but he has a passport he's
got to push it oh my goodness and we've seen a
case of over pressing now black spawn runs it's
more far advanced why does sandwich stand there
with this king this is losing now for andrew and
wow d2 and bishop d5 intercepting the rook
he's going to promote amazing knight f4 last
chance d1 queen that wins the game he is simply
going to give up his queen take the pawn and win
by giving his rook up four whites passer
and niho wins it unbelievable when um wow
no words mike crazy nice call at the end nihal
takes his biggest lead of the match a two-game win
and we've had two major themes this match
we've had wedge pawns and we've also had
inability to convert better positions white
we thought was slightly better the entire game
and wasn't able to pull it out so let's hear it
for the counter attackers of the world because
they're the ones getting the job done today
absolutely and andrew we see him throwing stuff
around his room he is raging just look at his face
he is so unhappy he was just banging his table
just kidding we see why he uh is one of the most
level-headed players out there now mike you made
us a promise okay and i'm not going to let you
not fulfill that promise so we need the reveal
of the player who's over 27 and was over 27 who's
never at a chess book could i give you my guess
uh yeah you can let me let me say the guess from
the chat but then you can take your guess somebody
said kaidon off no i said he was the trivia giver
okay uh the funniest answer was claude bloodgood
who um was serving a life sentence in prison
when he got his uscf rating but he's written
a book about 26.90 did he um famously did not get
invited to the u.s championship because he was in
prison um he was never 2700 feda although a very
funny guess somebody said paul morphy no we didn't
have ratings back then so uh nobody got the answer
right it wasn't yvonne chuck what is your guess
donya i was going to get peruvian grandmaster
julio granda zaniga that's it you get my paycheck
we actually had force a draw just got it believe
it or not how did you know julio grande zuniga
was the answer so i've actually played him a
couple of times and when i was playing him and
the first time i played it was 2011 i did some
research while i was preparing for the game and
i found some stories that he was one of the most
unconventional one of the most unconventional
paths to the top where he basically had never
read a chess book i read some interview with him
in preparation for my game with him and i
ended up playing him twice so i have some
personal experience so it's not like i it's
that impressive i just played him i did some
preparation and some research and uh this is the
exception that proves the rule everybody out there
chess books are good um as are lots of online
learning resources of course but i guess the
good news well i'm happy you got my question
right i wasn't rooting against you but that does
confirm the trivia question by kaidanoff that
julio granda zuniga of peru who did make 2 700
in this decade or i guess i should say last decade
he just barely got above it i never read a chess
book but uh pretty amazing stuff well mike i miss
our trivia nights at the uh castle chess camp in
atlanta the geography uh trivia so that is um
that is something we'll have to recreate that's
an awesome question i asked the players before
the tournament name a hidden skill that you have
and nihal wrote back to me and he said that
he knows quote quite a few world capitals oh
i i'm going to have to test that now if i may
appoint myself as the ultimate tester of that
i will um i know you're awesome i think nihal may
have been underselling not that we should take
wikipedia with a grain of salt but if you go to
nehal's wikipedia page it says that he could name
190 world capitals and country flags by the age of
three oh my are you did you see three now this is
wikipedia i don't know how we're going to be able
to confirm this i think we're asking that question
in the interview yeah nihal if your parents are
in the chat mr and mrs sarin um i don't know how
life is in carol of these days i hope it's great
tell me in the chat if in fact this story is true
are you kidding me that i mean now nihal was
already impressing me before but if this is even
halfway through even if you knew them by the age
of nine that is incredible yeah we'll we'll give
them some some tough country capitals yeah let's
think of some burundi i mean gotta think of some
good ones all right so we have asymmetrical pawn
structure equal material in the ending and we
have the white rooks bearing down on c5 although
if there's one strong point in black's defense
it is c5 i guess one of the questions i would have
is is white preparing b4 or d4 yeah he definitely
is um and by the way one one potential trick is to
ask him a country that whose capital has recently
changed such as kazakhstan and i think there were
a couple of others as capitalism i think uh don't
quote me on this but burma or myanmar uh that
uh capital has changed recently as well anyways
um to answer um your question i think he is
preparing b4 in order to potentially carve
out and he's not trying to win the pawn
on c5 so much as he is trying to carve out
that d4 square for his knight what black could do
is simply not react for example if you go before
i could drop my king to d6 and this pawn on c5
is very very well protected um why could still
put the knight on d4 because of the pin but
again it doesn't do much so andrew potentially
eyeing the possibility of creating a passer with
h5 um so let's see how knee hall handles that and
now a nitrate on the cards which would seem to
get a relatively dry shank and what nehal could
do is go king f3 rook h2 and actually target that
on um so maybe he does have a slight pull here
battle of the rook end game so far in the
three-minute segment and not sure what the odds
are so far but nihal's been doing just fine in the
three-minute um you know we've been making a joke
about not wanting to be the better player and not
wanting to be the person pressing i'm not sure who
i like in this end game it might just be that they
each have a weak pawn and they're going to toggle
let's see they neither one has been that willing
to bail out into a draw and there we go e4
uh knee hall not happy with the repetition and
is going to go for a passer with e5 i think
and look at those pawns now the one drawback of
that right is this f4 pawn is a little bit weak
and could be targeted with rook h to f8 but even
if you do that there might be a possibility of
going f5 check we'll get into that if it happens
in the meantime nihil sidestepping the pin he's
preparing something like f5 against maybe he's
preparing f5 even without rook f8 andrew trying to
cut into that pawn failings with h5 very good move
maybe f5 should be considered here by um nihal
let's see what he does very very structurally
complex position he does play f5 i really like his
position you look at these puns notice the pin uh
does not allow black to take on g4 here he takes
on f5 now he takes f5 would create the possibility
of rookie 6 check andrew going after the pawns now
rook g6 is going to be very powerful this is going
to be a devastating move rook g6 intercepting
blackstroke uh mike this seems to be spiraling
out of control train him like h4 i'm wondering
if you trade and play h4 just to prevent white
from getting connected passers okay he's actually
just going to give definitely a practical chance
yeah but now maybe g5 even rook takes h5 simply
and even if black takes you get not pass pawns
but two very far advanced funds spoiled for
choice is knee hull he does go for this also b6
is hanging this is definitely losing for andrew
i'm not seeing even a way for him to get practical
chances maybe he should go after the pawns as he
is king f4 or even king h4 to prevent the rook
later on from stopping upon with rook h3 should
be considered so nihil definitely thinking about
that two to one time advantage as well he can
also looking for him king takes e3 take the other
rook he goes king h4 okay let's see h6 and maybe
rook to g3 to intercept black stroke is what he
wants let's see i think rook g3 is what he wants
he does yeah and the rook's got to go to e1 and
e8 only well i thought that was the only action
that they know it's nh7 king g5 incredibly well
calculated andrew has got to activate his past
his passwords but not fast enough and he resigns
amazing end game performance by neo and now mike
this is getting concerning for grand master tang
as a three-point lead has been opened up by nihal
sarin exactly knee halls won four and a half out
of the last five to go from a two-point deficit
to a three-point advantage maybe i get my math
wrong there yeah i think he was actually only
down one game so he was down one now he's up three
thanks to having an undefeated final five games
and uh don't know what the match predictions
are looking like now but i would have to say
that nihal is probably up above 80 percent we'll
see if smarter chess can confirm that and this is
a pivotal moment this is where andrew has got to
stop the bleeding there is something unsettling
about being down eight to four right you're almost
lapping your opponent um and if you win a game
here it's only two points to me mike and i don't
want to do overly you know over prediction but it
seems like andrew with the white pieces here has
to try to score a victory and there we go there
we see the the talking head of nihal sauron
continually inching higher and he's climbing
a mountain while andrew's down in the valley so
uh rarefied air for the number one player the 16
year old getting the best of the 20 year old thus
far how much uh you know you covered the entire
knockout how much was andrew challenged he had
three matches on the knockout stage is that right
yeah and it was extremely close in all of them
okay uh particularly i think and don't quote
me on this the second match against uh van
nuyn from the czech republic was very close
it was back and forth now we saw a little bit of
nervousness from andrew in the beginning he was
even losing a couple of games on time um but then
by the end he kind of settled into his groove and
the final was an incredible display uh by angela
so he's one of those players i actually played a
match against andrew a couple of months ago as
part of my series of matches and at one point i
was up i think five or six points going into the
bullet segment which was actually 30-second chess
and andrew mounted a comeback he won five in a row
and he brought the lead back down to one so he is
more than capable of it by the way what happens
if nihal takes everything and then takes on c5
using this pin against white's queen i feel like
andrew may have blundered here let's see i think
he blundered that this is very concerning now we
had another b pawn that was poisoned there after
c5 black didn't even have to take a half a second
to avoid queen takes b3 where bishop d1 would
have become a problem so just another queen trap
we saw that i believe in game one of the match
black wasn't falling for here nihal too strong
for that exactly and um andrew definitely has
recognized that he could take with the bishop
but that does not help something like this might
be the lesser it will also look at the d5 square
that is a huge blockading square for a potential
black knight that could swing itself around to
d5 so positional advantage as well on top of this
this is highly highly unsettling for andrew now as
nihal goes for it and he can now swing his knight
around from d7 to f6 to d5 shutting the doors on
any counter play connected with this active bishop
on b2 i can see andrew touching his face in his
lips though that's about as concerned as it looks
like he gets is that some sort of certificate
in the background is that like his grandmaster
probably i see always in his streams okay maybe
intimidating his opponent with his feed agm
cert except they've all got it that's
the problem we've got 16 players in 16 gm
now this would be bad even if nihal were not up
upon this is a disastrous disastrous position
look at all of black's pieces harmonious
this d4 pawn is on the verge of collapse
and andrew has got to pull a miracle here in
this game to try to get this match under control
to stop the bleeding um yeah and he tries to
go into the opposite colored bishop end game
but the promise is not an end game there's rooks
and the queen's still left on the board i suppose
there are some drive tendencies but it looks like
like he's going to lose the spawn on d4 as well
yeah and uh although we've not had a scandinavian
any member of team scandi will definitely
appreciate the pawn structure for black because
this happens a lot in that opening where you plant
your pawns on c6 and e6 and you target the d4 pawn
the difference is white usually at least has a c
pawn to defend it and now that c pawn's been
chopped out it's like team scandy on steroids
so a bit of a strange illusion but i think the
pawn structure does bear mentioning no definitely
we had one opposite-colored bishop middle game
back in game two that andrew tang won but this is
not that game there's no queens on the board we're
closer to the end game than we are the middle game
and the d4 pawn he's not getting any safer he's
gonna be weak from now until the next morning
indeed indeed and um well andrew may be hoping
that that um certificate is going to give him
some strength but wow and i mean john bartholomew
like you said mike team skandy he would love this
position i mean hey guys john let's just take
on d4 here we got some black gate going guys
all right take on guys yeah but this is like
a dream scenario now again if you take on d4
with the bishop the one issue if you move the
bishop away it could lead to a trait of rooks
and we are zooming in look at look at
the camera angles here amazing stuff
we're trying to get a sense of um i think it's
the fide logo i mean it's got of what it says
all right andrew can you just move your face a
little bit uh yeah it definitely is something
feeling related okay and by the way i think it's
the gym side it's got to be the gym certificate
john was one of the first coaches i believe of
andrew although john is not going to want to watch
this position this is not what what what you want
um now black is the gm certificate i can confirm
this is what mine looks like too sorry go ahead oh
this is what my feed a pin looks like my f my fun
master pin it's the only fun master pin in the
world i assure you don't look at it too closely
black can play pawn to e5 here supporting the
bishop thus trying to avoid the mass trade of
rooks and by the way sometimes people say fun
master mike how'd you get that name dania it
actually happened at the castle camp because
i was surrounded by grand masters all the
kids were asking me one day hey fm what's that
stand for yeah it stands for fun master and uh
not it just stuck so interesting i i
didn't know that that's pretty cool and um
i like it fun master mike has a certain ring to it
now here's the problem for richard now if me hall
trades rooks that could still be losing for right
look at these funds they're all on dark squares
and here we go nehal still not training them
he's using his king in a very savvy manner
to take upon this is definitely losing for white
on top of it andrew six seconds he's desperately
trying to create something but nihal is
simply too solid here a6 training pawns
good try but i'm afraid it's not gonna be
enough this king could also infiltrate to f4
and again keep the rooks on the board give
yourself two chances to win you're gonna win
either on the clock or on the road there's always
that small chance if you trade rooks that white
can set up some amazing fortress uh but keep the
rooks on the board okay now the rooks are gone
but i don't believe there's a fortress when the
black king is so active and you could go a5 you
could even preserve the other pawn not that you
would need it he goes bishop h4 i i don't know
why he didn't keep the apon honestly but this is
a kind of famously winning endgame the strategy is
you move these pawns and without the
pair of b-pawns sometimes this is a draw
because the bishop would give itself away for two
pawns obviously here even if the bishop does give
itself away black is going to have that b-pawn
remaining so this is a very elementary win this
is almost checkmate as you can see white cannot
hold these pawns together they are going to push
um whether white likes it or not and i think we're
about to see another victory when the pawns are
side by side you should always push your pawns to
the light squares because they'll have no trouble
advancing to the dark squares so for all of our
fans that are listening they're a little bit new
to bishop end games watch how black keeps doing it
there's no problem getting those pawns to f2 and
g3 because that's the color you control if you
would push the opposite way a blockade could be
set up and once again black does it for the third
time black well he's about to i forgot we're in
analysis mode but yeah yeah and there we go that
is official he promotes does knee hold eight to
four ladies and gentlemen as this is spiraling
rapidly out of control with 27 minutes left
in the three-minute portion andrew has got to
make this a little bit closer i still think
he's the favorite of the bullet i think that is
his chance but with how good nehal is i mean it
can he's got to bring this at least to two and get
your hi-hat drums ready because andrew is bringing
messed up the joke andrew is breathing sarin gas
we're waiting to say it i think now is a good
time to say it is a good time to say it five
and a half out of the last six for the young
superstar from kerala the number one seed showing
why he deserves that title it was very close for
the first 85 minutes of this match until nihal
won a queen versus rook pawnless ending in the
final game with a five minute and then he's taken
three and a half out of four in the three minute
indeed indeed and uh uh be as the game is in its
opening stages let us remind you very quickly of
what these players are facing off for we have some
amazing prizes at every stage uh we can see that
basically the winner of the finals gets uh a cool
2 500 and what might be even more important for
the players qualification to the uh speed chess
championship and uh also important to notice is
that all of the games will be played even if
the match is decided uh because a percentage
of the prize fund goes based on the actual match
score so there is always incentive to win games
even if the actual results of match has
been decided so a lot to play for here
and these players mike are just putting themselves
on the line yeah so we're not going to see anybody
that's mathematically eliminated play the grub or
anything like that unless they unless they don't
care about the 50 bucks that they're losing
by by losing to a higher match percentage so
50 bucks to kids these days is important um it
should also be said that these players are not
making anything in over the board tournaments
right now because they haven't existed so um
you know internet chess is a bigger and bigger
deal it really is um and um it's great to see
you know the adaptation process taking place so
quickly in a very very difficult time for us all
um so many opportunities for these young players
who of course the progress of many of them is
curtailed by the absence of um over-the-board
tournaments very very difficult on so many
players who were at the apex of their chess
careers using this time to gain rating and to
to become grandmaster so not an easy time but
you know it's good to see chess.com doing as much
as it can to offer opportunities for these young
players who are hungry for competitive tournaments
an interesting moment that just passed us by the
knight took on d4 however if white had taken with
the pawn the white pawn would have been blockaded
so easily that is a completely unideal isolated
queen pawn position so white is instead opted
but for taking with the pawn keeping the pawn
symmetrical but you can see how his pieces
are invading nonetheless now wait a minute
here bishop b5 speaking of invading is nihal
simply winning a piece there because notice
the knight cannot move the bishop will be dropped
so white is attacking that bishop and i don't see
a good way to defend that knight bishop c8 i'm not
going to consider looking knight c6 this is going
to be a disaster so i'm pretty sure that nihal is
trying to figure out whether andrew has anything
up his sleeve against bishop b5 right off the
top of my head i don't see anything now there
is a weakness of the back rank that white has so
there might be some sort of hidden tactic here
but if there is i'm not saying maybe a6 and then
bishop d6 trying to get white to look out but even
rook takes b7 leads to two pieces for a rook at
the very minimum and i'm sure there's better than
that so nihol taking his time here but bishop b5
actually might be a crushing blow and if he wins
this game that would be a five-point lead andrew
you can't read anything by his facial expression
but mike he does seem to be a little bit unsettled
here he just threw himself back in his chair in a
way that suggests oh no what you know what's about
to befall me um knee hall looks about as intense
as ever not in a menacing way but in a man that
you could tap him on the shoulder right now and
he may not even react he's that glue that's it
he's locked in knight takes e6 is also a move
with queen g4 to follow a lot of threats here so
now that i'm looking at it that might be sort of
a quote-unquote safe for alternative and he does
it so he goes for knight 66 beautiful idea here by
nihal with queen g4 to follow now the point
is after fe queen g4 and that's what he was
calculating maybe there was something about bishop
b5 he didn't like i don't blame him because you're
threatening mate and you're threatening the pawn
on e6 but it's not about the pawn if you take that
pawn you also fork the knight there's a million
threats looming another thing to notice here
now the king walks into a pin boom queen takes
h6 goes the dynamite with bishop c4 to follow
this looks like a complete disaster for andrew
this that's pretty brutal and i would almost argue
that in a situation where both might be winning
he might just be trying to figure out which one is
easier to analyze and this may be easier you
had to show a couple of different variations
after bishop b5 that were a little tricky
here it's very forcing because bishop b5
uh it's not as threatening as knight takes
e6 because you're hitting the rook and you're
hitting g7 i don't see what you do if you
don't take this knight you can't allow knight
i was thinking briefly about knight to c5 trying
to kind of entomb this rook but again it's
so deflating because at the very minimum white can
give this rook back up and he's up upon i'm sure
that that is not the best way i can do but maybe
that is the lesser evil for andrew i don't know
um perhaps knight c5 has the effect of
muddying the waters nihal does have 32
seconds so andrew looking desperately for some
way uh to make things a little bit complicated
let's see what he chooses yeah i was almost
wondering if knight c5 if you could go crazy
and play queen g4 and that's not a very good
game management move but after knight takes
knight rook takes bishop on e7 threatening rook
takes the knight and yeah and you do have back
rank mate covered um again i'm not sure if it's
the best from a game management perspective
but it might work out um so for anybody at
home quote cheating with your eval bar on
yeah and he's gone for fe but one second
for andrew and he succumbs to the inevitable
this actually might happen queenie and
and he goes king h7 to avoid but now
e5 can come in with queen g6 to follow that is
just going to be immediate checkmate i think
uh for for knee hall he goes queen f5
first and then e5 i think will follow
we're going to see a resignation from andrew if
that happens he doesn't even have to do that he
can go yeah and he does beautiful beautifully
conducted attack when he holds so smooth
and a five point lead mic with how much time left
i think right around 20 minutes left we're gonna
confirm that in a second in the three minute
portion it ain't it's never over till it's
over mike you referenced before the biggest
comebacks ever made in the speedchest championship
could you remind us of the range that has been
uh you know that people have come back from
yeah uh there's been at least one four point come
back and at least one five this was confirmed
by smarter chess and this is this is jogging my
memory back a long time i believe the five-point
comeback was turned in by international master
yaakov norwicz who beat the chicago grand master
of course my my mind would blank uh of rook yes
boris was the opponent kind of surprising but you
know norwich is known for his internet chess
i believe that was a five game comeback now
interestingly in crush against tatiana kazinseva
crush had to win her final five games in the
bullet and i think she beat kazinsva by one game
so it was it was a literal last chance come back
and uh unlike every other nice story about
charlotte tatiana kazinsva played her match
at the charlotte chess center so it's about
the one negative thing we can say about the
city of charlotte today and the chess center is an
amazing place as well so um play your matches for
the cello chess center so uh so it's going to take
a historic comeback let me ask the chat because we
could speculate all day things were close up until
the 90 minute mark what do you think has changed
in this match to allow nihal sauron to win six and
a half out of seven i'd like to hear from our chat
you guys get to be um our mock commentators in
the chat uh let me know what you think was it an
opening choice was it a time management choice was
it something else because you've had the luxury of
pontificating while we've been trying to talk
our way through this maybe you can let me know
absolutely and we thank uh the thousands of
you who are still here with us watching this
fascinating match unfolds i have a feeling that
there's a lot of action left i'm not going to put
words in the chat's mouth but um i have a feeling
that there is going to be some intrigue here as we
have an interesting slop so looking forward
to seeing people's opinion yeah it's it's a
great question what seemed to change because it
seemed to be so subtle and all of a sudden boom
five point lead yeah and maybe the sample size
is too small to make a definitive um statement
about why i mean in fact the funny thing is were
it not for the draw in game nine knee hall would
have done a fabiano and by that of course i mean
win seven in a row but if you were to ask why did
fabiano win seven in a row in 2014 i don't know i
mean the sample size is pretty small he's always
been fabiano um but maybe there's a reason there
sometimes is a collective threat as to why that
was crazy fabiano that brings back some amazing
memories another memory that i had of a comeback
in the speech image which was not technically
speaking a historic comeback size-wise but match
between jan krishnaf duda and alexander grishok
i think rishik was up don't quote me on this and
i've said that multiple times but really don't
quote me on this i think it was up three points
with like five minutes left in the bullet and
judah came back and won four in a row it was fun
i was watching that from the charlotte chess so
the charlotte chess center seems to be involved
in some way shape or form in these comebacks maybe
i should make my way to the chess center right now
i'm pretty close i do remember that match you
don't you would not have expected the veteran
i'm not going to use the word collapse but to
allow i kind of come back but but grisha is a very
uncompromising player there's not he's not the
kind of person that says hmm i'm up three i'm
going to change my openings and try to manage
this match i mean greece shook he he gets what
you think he's going to give you that's why he's
so exciting to watch indeed we all love sasha and
okay i tried to win the match but okay young
christoph came back a little bit but okay this
is kind of what makes me strong so but okay here
we will see what andrew can bring to the table
um but anyways uh we have nehal with 40 seconds
now this is actually a shot for andrew he seems
to have a good position despite is he down upon
no he's not down apply so nihal's pod structure
is definitely something went wrong for him in the
opening andre has great central control let's see
if he can activate his pieces that knight on
c1 is a little bit stranded this knight on a5
is pressuring the b3 square so um andrew yep he's
protecting d4 he's preparing queen c2 and rook t1
15 minutes left in this portion and i've got to
believe that andrew's got to get this margin down
to at least three games is that five right now but
uh i think three is the number that he should be
he should be shooting for definitely three is
definitely surmountable so he needs to take
this one game at a time maneuvering here but nihal
has of course so strong in bullet as well and just
the way he's played here he's fast i mean he's
calculating swiftly he's not making any careless
mistakes and here we see him actually sacking
upon and he's probably just trying to open up
the c file for his rook maybe cement the bishop
with a5 at the end now the problem is at the end
of this line this knight on v6 could end up being
hanging and d5 could follow so he's got to be very
careful about that um i'm not exactly sure oh
what he wants is to take on c3 and go bishop a4
and pin the rook wow what an idea i'm telling you
he's finding some incredibly creative ideas but
andrew taking the ball on a7 sidestepping that
minefield so definitely big time advantage here
for andrew and almost no time remaining for anyhow
this is a game that he simply must carry home
yeah and the annoying thing for black is that you
always have to look for the center pawns advancing
like every single turn it's going to burn time
on your clock one of the other problems with
your opponent having what we call in chess kid
land the snow plow the two pawns side by side
in the middle because they tend to push stuff out
of the way and there we go the snowplow uh by the
way you did snow in colorado the other day somehow
that's happening in the world in september and uh
the snowplow here amounts to the bishops breaking
through the rook has come up and over and some
sort of queen c6 rook takes h6 ideas in the offing
all kinds of fun for the white pieces absolutely
queen c3 is also an idea at some point threatening
rook takes h6 mate and i like that you have names
for these things that we all kind of know but
don't have names in standard chess nomenclature
so the snowplow indeed serving andrew well
here and now he's got all sorts of mating ideas
h5 brilliant positional game thus far he's
just got to take it home nihal is so hard
to bring down and here we see he's creating some
threats so rookie 8 would win i think on the spot
uh but there is some stuff to calculate queen for
andrew choosing to place him oh rook taking c66
carlson karaoke and final game of the
world championship was rook takes h6
and there we go exactly different position
here but rook h6 wins another important game
it does and andrew brings this to four now would
you say this is another must-win game if he is
able to win this one that gives him even some
time in the three-minute portion so important
game for both players here as nihal goes back to
his trusty retti with b3 is he going to double
fianchetto again he's won some nice games
in that line he's gotten some good positions
andrew this time trying to curtail it by playing
bishop g4 now playing g3 doesn't make much sense
because of this pin yeah you're asking for trouble
i wouldn't call it must win because i look at the
match clock with 12 minutes and i think this is
probably going to be this game and maybe two or
three others so i'm not going to go so far as
to say must win i know we use that term a lot
but it would be nice to win it'd be really nice
if your name is andrew tang by the way you said
something interesting about the fact that we have
names for things i think it's really nice for kids
to be able to say ah snowplow stuff like that but
i'll also say that you don't have to have funny
names to be good and i'll tell you how i know this
i was on the set for gary kasparov's master class
and he actually said when he learned chess
in russian they did not differentiate between
pin and skewer yep they don't they still don't
they just called line attacks he said i actually
this is hilarious i always have trouble even in
my streams i i confuse the two even now i will say
skewer when i mean pin and pin and i mean skewer
because in russian there's only one word skasca
that describes both uh both so fun fact i can
totally contest that because i also learned chess
in russian um and there is indeed only one word
for both yeah and decoy deflection they're all
kind of the same thing so you don't necessarily
need to know the terms however when you're making
funny videos like i do which is pretty much my
whole life having a snowplow go across the screen
has a little bit more memory for a kid than um
than just using a big four-syllable word that's
exactly right and decoy i also i always say the
word distraction which i don't think is a formal
name for anything but in russian that word for
decoy deflection literally means distraction
um so i always use that but i completely agree
with you mike and it could really help i think
kids learn positional chess when you have you
know somewhat fun names to refer to things they
can sort of more specifically understand certain
content so i think that's fantastic work and
it really is uh it's awesome now there is one
time danya where you have to get the word right
and this is a fantastic story when uh when
when hillary clinton was secretary of state
she was meeting with the russian secretary of
state oh it is sergey lavrov and she was trying
to tell her counterpart hey let's reset relations
with our countries and she accidentally had one of
her assistants that spoke russian misinterpret a
word which is a chess word uh i believe the little
button that she presented said perry perry gruska
instead of perry zagruska exactly she was telling
her counterpart i'd like to overload relations not
reset relations so can you confirm though is the
russian word for overload perigruska peregregruska
yeah so you can say like uh fierspirigren like the
queen is overloaded now but the thing is the
word pity zagruska is so is incredibly rare
so it's already asking for trouble like that
is that is a very like abstr you know kind of
an esoteric word that's not used often so it
was already a weird choice to begin with and
russian is it's the kind of language where you
can switch around one syllable one letter in it
and it really changes the meaning of the the word
i do remember that story actually yeah and we've
got national master and chess kid star brewington
hardaway the former top 10 year old in the usa
has joined us in the chat we're probably
overloading him with russian language lessons
so back to our game we have a symmetrical pawn
structure a little more space for white and
what i see are very strong pieces in the
center but i like the white knight on e5
even more than what than black's bishop on e4
yeah and what niho could consider playing f3
and drop and then this bishop on d5 we've seen
this before it could actually get sort of stranded
in the center uh so andrew actually well we have
a train and nihal is definitely pressing here
look at this knight on the two we could jump
to a5 and it could start frustrating black's
pawn so the sort of symmetrical position does not
tell the whole story andrew has some work to do
in order to draw this and hold his own he could
consider trading rooks and then defending the pawn
one thing that could happen the trade works and go
b6 the knight can start hunting down these pawns
let's see what he does this has happened so knight
c8 is interesting i'm not sure that it gives
enough to be able to generate true winning chances
but this is going to get interesting for sure
and let me just queue up brewington hardaway
here chess kid star who do you like in this
position burrington do you agree with
the analysis or do you want to go your
own way i'm going gonna let you type in
the chat i'll read whatever you type in
probably a little too early for for match
management but this game has gone on so long
last time i took a look at the match clock we
had dipped below eight minutes it's very possible
that there will only be one more three minute
game after this one and if you're the leader
generally you do want longer games that shortens
the number of remaining games in the match so
i i think it's still a little early to do
game management or match management in the
three-minute segment but it certainly doesn't
hurt nihal that these games are going so long
uh-huh interesting and and by the way this
king from f1 it could walk all the way to
e6 potentially using those light squares as a
passageway and applying pressure on black spawns
so let's see what knee hall comes up with andrew
pressed to the back of the wall here he's kind of
paralyzed but i'm curious what brewington what
brewington thinks about this position as well
yeah and actually that's a funny reason why you
may not want to play knight takes b8 soaks soon
because after knight takes it does cover the a6
square so maybe you wait for your king to get to
a6 before you take now i doubt that black is just
going to sit there and allow all that to happen
but the knight is in no hurry to take the bishop
on b8 yeah it's incredible how paralyzed black is
he literally cannot dislodge the knight from c6 he
can't move the knight can't get the king to attack
the knight this and f4 further restricting black's
position stopping ideas of 95 is knee hall now he
is saddling himself with this potential weakness
but if you go e5 look at this position incredible
andrew might at some point have to part ways
with one of his queenside puns but that is a
disastrous loss in an endgame i think he simply
lost i think that this is simply winning for
white yeah black is really not able to find any
space here by the way brewington does concur
he likes white more and if you want to play
brewington he plays every saturday in the month of
september on chess kid go to the chess kit
calendar and see when he's playing next however
what we're focusing on right now are two of
the best grandmasters in the world especially
when it comes to online chess but we see nihal
seren looking to put the match back to the five
point margin indeed and just one more shout out to
brewington i had the privilege of commentating the
um danker and rockefeller tournaments a couple
of weeks back and i was quite impressed with
brewington's play throughout the tournament so
definitely a shining star of american chess best
wishes to you uh on your path and here we see
nehal taking the king's path to c4 he's going
to take one of these pawns the bishop is going to
drop back to f2 in order to restrict black's king
uh from coming to h4 here we see a pass pawn being
created this is definitely completely winning for
white black's king is simply not in time he's
too cramped the e6 pawn is weak black is on his
back foot on his last legs this pawn is running
this game is over i agree we remiss if we didn't
say that the reason that white won the pawn is
because the knight was perry's perigruska it is
a yeah exactly this is perigruska very much yeah
and another win here for niall extending this
lead pushing it back up to five and quite possibly
the last game like of the three minute portion is
upon us right they will parry zagruska the pieces
for one more game in the knights we'll go back i
only know two russian words they happen to be very
complicated russian words but uh a five point lead
nobody's ever come back from a greater margin than
five points um and it looks like they're the odds
are 86 i'm actually surprised they're not
higher but 86 percent odds for nihal sarah
and that means he's going to win approximately
seven out of eight matches where he has a five
point lead of this segment i'm really surprised
we're not up above 90 percent i'm not saying
i'm gonna lay eight to one odds on andrew or
anything like that but i'm just a little bit
surprised because i don't see anything that
suggests that knee hall would not be above
90 but smarter chess has the numbers i just have
the guesswork i don't actually have the ability to
to do the math no i think it's actually i mean
and neohal taking his time here on move too um
get the camera back up on the players is he having
some sort of i mean it looks like his internet's
okay you know what's funny is if you have like an
emergency restroom situation you i mean you only
have to lost one more game before the the break
but no he's there why do i have some stories about
that so finally he makes a move now this is a
pivotal game in terms of the odds again if andrew
wins this four points is very much surmountable
for him if nihal wins the six point lead i mean
anything is possible but this is i mean this
is really i feel like potentially be the match
deciding game so andrew with the white pieces
we know how dangerous he is we have sort of a
symmetrical a queen a4 check there is a move i'm
i'm not too familiar with this line i think white
is slightly better if he goes knight c3 as far
as i know um and they do go into this end game
but i'm sure any hall is very well prepared and
it can be very frustrating when you're trying
to win an end game like this and you feel the
advantage slipping away from you let's see uh
whether andrew will be able to put pressure g3
is an interesting way to develop the bishop here
fiance may be putting more pressure on black
another request in the chat for trivia that seems
to be my main utility in commentating i think i
only have one question left and besides we can't
ask trivia during the bullet so i'll go ahead
and final my final absolutely my final trivia
bullet here this is probably the easiest question
i'm going to ask you but we asked all the players
before the jscc began which player would you most
like to have dinner with past or present so alive
or not alive i'm so used to saying kids shows we
don't say the word dead but whatever all right
pastor present so again we couldn't quite get
our questions to andrew tangentine because he
disqualified so i have the answer for nihal type
it in the chat who do you think nihal sarin would
most like to have dinner with you're probably
not going to be surprised by the answer which
is the biggest hint i can give you hmm that's it
i think i could take this in various directions
i could i could see it being vishy i could see
it being fisher i could see it being gary um
i mean there's so many mouth-watering guests
who could have at the dinner table you know one
guy i personally would love is mikhail tal who
was incredible uh just character in addition to
being of course a legendary chess player but i'm
very curious mike i actually don't know uh can i
give you my favorite mikael talk quote please
do when he was told about a soviet-era plan
to eradicate alcoholism mikhail tall said the
state against vodka i'll be on the side of vodka
and of course that was part of his undoing but
what an amazing player and we might not see a
player that creative again because you could
simply do stuff back then that's not possible
today i mean bador jobova and grieshook and
they're all trying their best richard rapport but
mikhail tall will always be the industry standard
for creative chess uh nezmetanov too but i think
mikhail told he did it with success more than any
other player exactly and he's always been my idol
you know as i've tried to go crazy a couple times
but he is he's a legend and uh you know one of
those people who was a man of the world you know
he had so many interests and very well read and
you know just uh there's an interview with him
that has english subtitles from the late 80s
toward the end of his life and he shares some
fascinating insights into his lives and stories
and uh you know you just got to cherish people
like that and what they have brought to the table
and there's a trick here if rook b1 i
think knight takes b2 might be the idea
book takes b2 and then you take and it is a fork
now castles is possible yep and you avoid that
because then the king can take definitely andrew
with the edges he has fianchettoed his bishop
which makes it very hard for black bishop to
develop without giving up a pawn maybe black
needs to part ways with that pawn anyway rook d4
definite pressure being put by andrew knee hall
also with 30 seconds on his clock so this is this
is looking good in the early going here for andrew
as he can bring his knight to c5 also yeah one
of those rare times we actually castle right onto
the open files but again you can't play chess on
general rules you have to take the demands of the
position and see um you know what rule applies or
needs to be broken uh black's got some development
problems here with the b7 pawn being so weak yeah
and also you know white can consider bringing his
rook into the game with rook hd1 white needs to be
careful his pawn structure he's got a lot of pawn
islands his pawn structure isn't great so bishop
v8 here would be possible by the way and then
maybe drop the bishop back to c7 i actually quite
that seems rather mouth-watering uh but he doesn't
have to he can also just double rooks um and as
we've discussed he's got to make the decision
quickly keep that time adventure i i do like rook
hd1 because then you could bring the rook to the
eighth rank and black's pieces are in a lot
of trouble the bishop and the knight are both
undefended he does just that we all know the quote
the threat is stronger than his execution so you
keep it should be it in your back pocket you could
play bishop v8 even here and if rook takes v8
there's a back break mate uh so but this is just
for show i don't think that it's actually any good
could have played bishop b in the last move
and then gone back to f4 i once uh going back
to gregory kadanov he once taught a two-hour
class about why you should always repeat once
now i never knew that you could give two hours of
reasons but he didn't wow it was awesome i really
enjoyed it yeah okay donna's lectures are amazing
i had such a good time in the u.s chess school
taught by kaidana he's awesome he's a good guy and
a great teacher and his life story is amazing uh
confirmed this is the final game of the three
minutes so if nihal sarin manages to win
he's not winning but if he manages to win
he will go into the bullet with the biggest
the most insurmountable lead that anybody's ever
come back from but he looks like he is losing
and big win for andrew bringing the lead
to four points it is still a very big lead
an amazing performance by nihol in the three
minute portion as our score is officially 10
points for knee hall 6 for andrew as the three
minute portion concludes um what a turnaround
here what a performance by nihol but andrew
winning the last game and um he gives himself
at least mike a fighting chance yeah he wins
two or the last three he stood up right away and
i actually saw nihal either talking to himself a
little bit or shaking his head up and down maybe
somebody in the room was just confirming what
this score is so four points is still going to be
an unbelievably tall order when you're playing the
number one seed but at least we still have a match
and if there's one thing that
andrew tang is synonymous with
it is bullet and so he's walking right into his
best discipline indeed he is we have 30 minutes of
bullet coming up for you we will see
whether andrew can find it in himself
to mount an incredible comeback or whether nihal
will deliver the hammer blow but first we're
going to rebuild our coffees and the players
will refill theirs we will go on a short break
and when we come back 30 minutes of bullet as the
final portion of this incredible match is upon us
so
and ladies and gentlemen welcome back to the
junior speed chess championship brought to
you by chess kid we have the final portion uh
the bullet portion of nihal sarah versus andrew
saying an amazing match uh coming your way
very shortly but first let's walk through um
a couple of details first and foremost let's take
another quick look at uh the bracket mic and see
what mouthwatering matchups we have coming up
starting uh tomorrow i believe with grand master
raunak sadwani uh competing tomorrow so mike any
thoughts about what we see here on the bracket um
not to correct you but i believe on my
schedule it says eragassi is playing google's
yeah my back my bad it is very guy you're right
the winner of this match will play smirnoff versus
sadwani and by the way whenever that match
happens we have the most adorable picture
of smirnoff when he was five years old so
you're going to want to tune into that match
just to watch that picture but tomorrow exact
same time 9 a.m pacific noon eastern 5 p.m uk
7 p.m for my friends in vilnius you will see
aragossi against gucash another great match
and then if you really um are up late in australia
and you want to watch your boy smirnoff play
sadwani you have to wait till september 23rd
but um we've got a month-long action of the best
juniors in the world so a lot to look forward to
absolutely and to take another quick look at our
statistical prediction we have seren predicted to
win the final against sam seven we see here and
a very impressive performance thus far in this
match so he is indeed making a case for himself
uh but we know how unpredictable things can be
every single one of these matches uh is going
to be so incredibly close and they are not just
playing for honor they are also playing for very
serious prizes uh as we remind ourselves quickly
the winner of the whole thing gets a cool uh two
thousand five hundred dollars and a ticket to the
coveted speed chess championship itself uh but we
see everyone gets a prize 500 750 for the winner
of round two guaranteed um incredible prizes and
we see the players putting their blood sweat and
tears on the line for every one of these matches
uh as we transition back and we will have
liftoff any second on 30 minutes of oneplus
one and a herculean task mike awaits andrew
who has to surmount a four point lead uh that
nihal seren has currently has and nihal is also
one of the greatest bullet players in the world
yeah he dug himself a big hole with about a 30
or 40 minute stretch of substandard chess or at
least results-wise where nihal got that big
lead by winning six and a half out of seven
you take that away and andrew's actually got
a small lead in the match andrew got himself
back in the match by winning two and a half
excuse me two out of three to close out the
three-minute segment he has a four-point
deficit his biggest deficit was actually
five and that has been surmounted before in a
previous match of this ilk several years ago so
everything to be decided and even if things
get mathematically out of his hands you're
still playing for prize money because the margin
of victory does matter for all of our matches
absolutely um and uh that's what makes these
patches so fascinating uh you know and and
just your body we will play even if the match
is decided every game is played in the allotted
time limit because part of uh the prize is
determined of course by the match score so
buckle in for 30 minutes of action and here we
go with yet another uh kind of ready structure
and andrew has got to play for a win with
black with white he cannot afford to kind of
trade baskets right he's got a he's got
to get some black games here as well
exactly no time for an analysis board either
everything's going to be shown live we probably
will expect at least eight bullet games sometimes
you see as many as nine or ten uh the players are
so fast though that can actually elongate the
games because they can play 90 or 100 move games
because they're they're so good with that one
second increment so i wouldn't expect too many
what i'm trying to say is i think andrew needs to
think about going six and two i think six and two
is the number you shoot for and then you hope for
the best in a tie break um i'll need a refresher
on the rules do we have do we go straight to
armageddon or do we play a couple of one plus one
games i have a feeling we play a couple of oneplus
one games but we'll get that confirmed uh by the
production crew but i think if andrew even gets
the tie break he i mean he'll be you four again
he'll cross that bridge when he gets there yeah
so we have confirmed we have four more games of
one plus one in the event of a tie and if that
is also tied then we go into an armageddon match
right five plus three but we're you know we're
just basically we're letting you know because it
will happen at some point in the next month that
may not happen today right and uh exactly so we
have andrew with a nice position you better get
20 seconds he has led his clock dip and we know
he's not afraid of that but against knee-hill nego
knows exactly how to pose problems he's playing a
lot faster we have h6 g5 now white doesn't have a
knight to stick on h5 this time at niho closing up
the position and preparing a queenside pawn from
this has gone a little bit south here for andrew
i like neal's position and very little time
remaining on the clock easy play for white as
he begins to attack the queen side black gearing
up for e5 i think black would have preferred to
play d take c4 a long time ago and try to play
against the hanging pawns but i guess he did not
like the space advantage that white conferred he
gets his e5 in but here comes the passer and rook
takes is not allowed because of bishop b5 with the
world's worst pin slash skewer depending on your
russian language terminology of all time exactly
and now that pawn on c6 like a splinter and andrew
trying to retail his pieces this looking very
very bad now he's got to make anyhow use some
of his clock which he is does he take on e5 and
expose that d5 pawn is the key question rook to e3
ah what an idea rook to e3 andrew going after
the spawn on c6 but now all of his resources
are tied down but what does nihal do bishop a6
wow and now bishop takes the 80s one in exchange
the game far from over though andrew has a plan on
a piece he's trying to activate his queen but he
gives up d5 this is looking very very rough now
a full exchange up for very little compensation
andrew's got to whip something up but nothing
seems to be on the cards his bishops are simply
too passive a5 now a6 is hanging the rook can come
in to see seventy hull going for a queen trade
look how carefully he's converting that king is
perfectly safe it has the h2 square uh this seems
to be essentially over uh barring some sort of a
miraculous blunder by knee hall one of those weird
positions where you have just enough thought
that you could make a comeback where you don't
resign but it's gonna cost you 30 more seconds of
match clock and there he goes he finally resigns
in a five point game now basically must-win
territory truly must win territory for andrew
there is enough time 26 minutes left they
will get at least five games in probably more
but every game needs to be a golden performance
now for andrew you want to put much time there
right mike i think yeah my prediction will be
seven more but that means you gotta go six and one
but not much yeah as we said crush against
kazinseva would be the the model comeback that
we're looking for where crush won the final
four bullet games to i think beat cozensva
in the playoff but the point is you don't really
want to rest your hopes on having to run the table
we would call that dormian golf you don't want to
end up dormy as black where you have to run out
to be able to survive right and it seems that
andrew isn't doing very much to win this game
he's simply worse than an in-game i
think he blundered something there
now just to remind the fans here we are not
obviously we are not rooting against nihal uh but
simply obviously we we do want to see intrigue so
it does not come out of a bias but rather because
um you know we obviously are always looking
for a comeback but not to take anything away
from nihal's performance so far which has been
absolutely incredible to have such a score against
a bullet and blitz wizard as such as andrew
is a very very impressive performance indeed
we had a quick splash of the real-time odds still
exactly 86 percent for nihal quite mysterious to
me because he was at 86 percent about an hour ago
with the same five-minute margin you would think
the same margin with less time on the match
clock would make his odds go up but the point
is 86 percent so however those numbers are derived
but uh the point is uh i still think it should be
above 90 like i thought the first time indeed and
um wow i'm just impressed that nihal is holding
his own ear in the bullet this is going to be a
dead draw which of course favors neil he wants
to bleed as much clock as possible take that
one away otherwise it goes to h6 tricky move
by andrew but not good enough and uh yeah i mean
this is probably going to be a draw one thing i
would try to do if i were now maybe andrew is now
worse he's by the way he's down two pawns mike
this other rook coming into d2 now he's the one
who has to make a draw um and he wants to do that
as quickly as possible trying to give himself
as much time as possible to continue the match
so frustrating because you have to burn another
minute of match clock and just hope for the draw
now i've heard of people saying in situations
like this probably not this situation but that you
should just go ahead and resign but mathematically
that loses another half point that you have to
recover which takes time to recover so i don't
actually believe there's really any scenario
where you should try to resign a drawn position
to save match clock it's it seems very unlikely
to me that i don't ever want to do that mate it's
right on the board but rook d8 i was going to say
now wait a minute that was a very tricky idea
andrew but niho finding the defense here look
at how carefully he is defending he doesn't mind a
draw um but i would go for it yeah and the reason
he's doing this is because he can simply bleed
another minute off the clock with that increment
um he can all there's nothing wrong with it he's
not doing anything dirty he's trying to win this
position which is by the way not an easy draw on
h5 wins the game andrew blundering h5 and this
is disaster as he will lose this one as well and
double whammy as nihal burns more and more time
mike this is the kind of territory where i would
already consider resigning because actually saving
this objectively is going to be very hard yeah
unfortunately we did not get to see the king
and 2 versus king and 1 technique so white was
correct if your goal is to try to draw to keep
the rooks on the board because at least you can
check and maybe create some confusion but you're
right it's ultimately lost and that would make
it six match point uh margin which would be uh
of historic proportions if white was attempting
to make a comeback white being andrew tang
indeed now i may have spoken too soon andrew
trying to kind of tie his rook to that pawn on e6
is he going to hold this together at this point
it's not quite a moot point but rookie two so
he's trying his best but does h2 and black's idea
to give up that each one for the e pawn and that
is a theoretical win if it happens i don't see a
defense here for android because now rookie one
you take e3 he resigns six point lead for nihal
and now with 22 minutes left he's got to score
a couple miniatures and although nobody's really
been asking i did leave you hanging on the last
trivia question nepal wants to have dinner with
vichy i mean was he really allowed to say anything
else i mean first of all i don't think he's just
saying it um you know vishy really has that kind
of stature in the indian chess world in fact
he's not the only player to give the answer vichy
we'll release those as few future matches come
out but here we see a crippling of black's pawn
structure is andrew a player that goes on tilt
uh or is it a is i can't even say his decision
guys he does i mean everybody does at some point
when the frustration reaches a boiling point
i think he's a lot less prone to tilt than
most um and even andrew's tilt is you know
not comparable to tilt of other players you
know myself included i'm capable of playing
on h4 and a4 and move one and just slam stuff
or andrew you know maintains a cool head but
sometimes there's this middle ground between tilt
and frustration where you're not outwardly tilted
but you're just your quality of play goes down
as you're another bad position another blunder
you get into these loops and i think here we
see one of them look at nihal's 3365 rating i
mean that is not a fluke that is how well this
guy plays um and uh this is again spiraling out
of control is andrew losing some pawns the
king side incredibly weak as well wow 33.65
that's not a chess reading that's a rush song that
is just amazing to get your rating up that high
another mate on the board but queen g4 covers
the bishop with check and now we'll probably see
well he's probably worried about g3 and then rook
g8 or something like that right but then queen
h5 may be threatening checkmate now that
does create a pin so something like this
the bishop cannot take the rook because of the
pin on the queen so black could play rook g7
problem is why it's okay just having that position
so andrew trying to go for tricks here and he's
succeeding this is interesting now but oh the
matrix and the thread of the rope look at that
and andrew loses this one all of a sudden the
rook on seat is hanging and mate is threatened
and he resigns another one and he resigns another
one three in a row for the south indian superstar
and um so far andrew not able to show his best
form in the discipline that he ostensibly is
best known for yeah and now we we talked
about this in the beginning of the match
mike how much do you think the increment
is has impacted this match uh in retrospect
um that's a great question i mean definitely
in the five-minute segment the players were
playing in such a way where the increment was
important because they were willing to bleed their
clock below a minute still in complicated middle
games so i guess the genesis of your question is
how differently would they have played the slower
time right without the increment i don't have
a great answer for you um so i'd like to turn
this one back on you because i actually don't
know enough about the players to say how they
would have played differently in the five minute
i think some of the time scrambles would have
probably gone andrew's way i think he's still
marginally better in that so that i think
favorite nihal um but again it's it's uh it's
always interesting to me how something ostensibly
small can really create a big impact or not so it
takes age three takes h3 indeed in queen h1
if you so he snaps upon off the board now
white's king again very weak b5 well that then
they would follow knight a5 but definitely nihil
once again in the driver's seat um as andrew's
london is on fire h5h4 is another idea here
to try to get this bishop on g3 off the board and
weaken white's king's side further going back to
your question adding the one sacrament chess is
basically a game when you reduce the time control
you're adding sport and you're lessening science
right like we could have the most accurate game of
chess ever played if we gave the players 24 hours
per game so adding the increment basically says
we already know these matches are played
incredibly fast to make them more sport but we're
adding a little bit of science because we want
players to be able to convert winning end games
and we want we don't want random we don't want
people sacrificing their queen for no reason
to to nullify a pre-move to win by a half a
second right so i appreciate the increment
for that reason because we're not judging reflexes
we're still trying to judge chess and the balance
for me is perfect with the one second increment
i think that's a fair point and i think that if
you know we like the time scrambles and we have
them it's not that one point a second increment
eliminates it by the way i think you invented a
word did you say sacrament because that's like a
second ending increment i like that way that's
like what do they call it portmanteau yeah i think
i think i uh sometimes i i think i have a speech
impediment sometimes when i'm speaking because i'm
trying to say things as quickly as you're moving
them on the board i'm just trying to keep up with
you no i feel you completely it can be it can
be tough but i actually like that so i agree we
see the time scrambles but we also see very very
high quality chests even in the bullet as we see
knee hall this way and that way he is feeling out
white's king side f5 is on deck and that is just
going to destroy the last line of defense here
bishop takes f3 to follow if the knight moves
potentially um this is not looking good once again
for andrew and you know sometimes when it rains it
pours it can be tough to watch it can be tough on
a player when it seems like nothing is going right
um so you know one has to just feel feel andrew's
pain here but with that being said knee hall is
is playing just a fantastic match with every
move black is giving white something to worry
about and white has not gotten a chance to get his
pawns mobile those pawns are sitting there and not
bothering black and the least and the black pieces
are either making a check a capture or a threat
virtually every turn exactly and another threat
there there was a check bishop b2 being threatened
andrew is defending this really well though he is
up a lot of pawns but the attack still rages on
one second though for niho let's see if andrew can
score oh and he gives the rook ah and another one
bites the dust here andrew defending very well
he's trying to get him with this queen but now
everything the roof comes off another night is
and everything is captured here now a bear king
and andrew resigns another victory resounding by
knee hall as he inches toward 3 400 bullet that is
incredible pretty amazing stuff an 8 point match
lead mathematically it's going to be well i don't
know what kind of math i can invent to make this
work we're gonna have to uh we're gonna have to
like you know what what's that kind of chess
where we're gonna make like the three-point
contest where the final couple games are worth
two points or something we'd have to change the
scale but they are playing for money it's real
money it's a split of five hundred dollars so um
right now it's two to one it looks like 333
dollars extra for nihal and 166 for andrew
wait it's not two to one it's fourteen to six okay
andrew please win this game so the math becomes
easy right exactly yeah no this is and by the way
okay so queen p2 your knee hole again look at the
pressure that he puts with every move you brought
this up in the last game mike there is just this
sense that he's playing with as my coach would say
playing with energy you know every move creates
a threat creates problems now there's problems on
the c5 and on the diagonal he's threatening bishop
takes c6 that this is actually a crushing move and
he's threatening bishop takes g7 amazing uh so all
of a sudden it's such a peaceful looking position
we've seen him do this a lot of times all of a
sudden creating what seems to be insurmountable
problems now bishop f1 attacking the queen
g7 is going to fall and that is going to be
what seems to be virtually another crushing blow
wow yeah in fact it might be two pawns after
bishop h8 because you have to play queen g6 you're
right yeah but then rook c7 might come in perhaps
so bishop h6 he does something similar now i would
just drop the bishop back to f4 sit on my extra
pawn and the wii king the rook can come into c7
queen queen to a3 look at the bishop on f1 sort
of incurring the king's side completely h5 andrew
trying what he can but i think white can go after
the pawns now and then at his leisure play h4
and a lot of pride in andrew's game here
being such a good bullet player i'm sure
he wants to scoop up some wins not just
for the extra lunch money but to remind
people of how good he is and bullet rook
c8 first move that comes to my mind here
completely agree i think that's a great
move trading forcing the trade of brooks
queen a4 though i think he's prioritizing
stopping h4 as the queen controls that square
uh and and you're absolutely right andrew is is
a legendary bullet player you know i think he's
a little bit off today in some regards but yeah as
another pawn collapses rook a5 can now be met with
queen e8 check saving the bishop so three puns
now uh for uh for knee hall i do think this was
good for nihal's ultimate tournament chances
by being tested in this opening round i know
that the final score won't reflect it but don't
forget he was down for much of the five minute
um and it wasn't until the transition of the
three minute where he started to open up a lead
um so i think that's nice now i want to question
you i know the matches were played a couple of
days ago but do you think andrew he's 20 years old
could he possibly be a little bit fatigued or are
these players so used to playing so much internet
chess that three matches several days ago has no
impact on a friday match today well to answer your
question i think fatigue is one of those things
from experience that strikes when you don't really
you don't feel it on a surface level you think i'm
pumped i got some sleep i feel good but then you
look at your play and you can just sort of see
the signs of tiredness and you see the you
know the sort of occasional uncharacteristic
blunder so it's a very insidious threat um
and that's that's the scary thing about it
um you just sort of you know the adrenaline
seems to replace uh it seems to make you
feel like you're awake and alive but it's just
inevitable these processes that wear you down
uh they just kind of take place whether
you like it or not so i absolutely think
that is uh an issue i also think andrew is
incredibly resilient he plays so many of these
incredibly long matches that take hours and hours
so he's pretty much primed for that but these are
some very very high stakes matches and uh it
can be hard to maintain the same level for sure
by the way in the opening game we never got to
actually show people why e4 did not work for white
white actually had a second chance to play it
but again it didn't happen now the difference
between this and i believe the very first game is
that white played rook c1 before the black queen
even got to c2 not that queen c2 was winning but
it certainly was complicated for white to figure
out what to do with that queen so that's the main
difference between this and the opening round game
good point indeed and uh now a solid position
for andrew but it is also for nihal again we see
that weakness of the king side and in bullet i've
always felt like that when you make a weakness on
your king side that's always accentuated and it's
not a particularly deep point it's just harder to
defend and bullet so like every little deficiency
can be amplified uh because of the just limited
time you have to defend congratulations to all the
fans of nihal sarin i bet you're still up in the
chat it's almost 1am in india so uh thank you for
not netflixing and chilling and instead watching
the end of your countrymen uh nihal sarin is going
to take this opening round match the question is
by what score and by how much money and could he
possibly have a perfect bullet against andrew test
i mean that that would be a feather in your cap
to be able to say that you ran the tables in the
bullet against andrew tang indeed and this game
looking good for nihal again despite his time
deficit look at his pieces all of them
playing bishop before rookie four he's
going to double rooks if that happens
um andrews king is also under fire
um and indeed for nihal playing very late uh
continuing to maintain such a high level is
just incredibly impressive bishop c7 going after
the pawns now what's the pawn count i think andrew
was technically up upon but he's going to lose it
i think f4 is going to be captured this does look
defensible for white but boy is it wow if if
niho runs the table on the bullet that will be
just an unbelievably impressive feat against
andrew he is down two to one as far as time so
i seriously doubt it will happen because even
after this game we've got at least three more i
i mean how can you put your money on andrew
losing three or four bullet games in a row
regardless of what's happened to this point but uh
but we'll see i guess that'd be as close as chess
comes to like a perfect game in baseball or
something right and i think this one i think
uh andrew does have a chance with three seconds
of the clock for me although his pawns are very
very concerning okay takes this might be a
draw actually i mean it starts to liquidate
on an h4 though you have to defend
it maybe rook h2 he gives it away
okay so he gives it away but he activates his
pieces i think nihal might just force a draw here
i mean there's really no need unless he is trying
to whitewash andrew yep in a draw upgrade so
there we have it what a disappointment
mike neo onyx i mean this is rejected
draw wow i mean terrible performance
to show didn't adopt andrew come on
to show you what i don't think 16 year olds
can adopt they're not of legal age to show you
what kind of fighting match we've had only the
third draw in 22 games you've only had one draw
in each of the three time controls that's pretty
low uh when it comes to we'll call it deathmatch
standards i'm showing my age when i use the term
death match we haven't had an official death match
in about two or three years but uh yeah 19 of
the 22 games have been decisive and unluckily
for the minnesotan or i should say the minnesotan
uh the the young player from kerala is doing well
absolutely he is and we've seen him repeating with
great success this particular type of line where
he can get us either one or both bishops ready
structure and he starts to harass blacks on center
as we see andrew trying to counteract his
activity by deploying his queen attacking
the bishop attacking pawn but um yeah so now a
decision to be made by neo as he defends both at
the same time guarding his bishop uh but you know
we'll see if andrew was able to score an honorable
or two as we are down to eight minutes left in
this incredible matchup and uh mike i'm just
so excited this is only the beginning we have so
many more awesome matches uh to come so i'm really
just excited to be here and to be commentating
and uh hopefully we've still got oversea you know
we've got thousands of you still watching whether
it's late in india we really appreciate it so big
shout out to all of the fans uh cheering on new
hall and andrew here as we enter the final stages
of the match and uh in the most self-deprecating
comment of the day i could say that if i was knee
hall here i could even win this match and i
say that because you could literally let your
one minute expire on the next five or six games
run the match clock down to zero and still win
comfortably but they are playing for money they're
playing for pride all of india is still watching
so thank you for not watching jay leno or whatever
the the up at night late um indian version of that
show is and we've got some tricks on g7 here we do
bishop g7 here is really strong followed by queen
g4 and then bishop on g7 will be independent
knight takes g7 preserving his bishop that is
equally as good double whammy there with the
rook 98 is possible as his knight h5 look at
this knight swinging around it nights at close
quarters like this with the king being exposed
are so dangerous and we see it here andrew will
have to give up his rook i think four night queen
g4 followed by queen c8 as possible rookie one
is also possible involving the rook as he does
impossible to defend this with three seconds queen
g4 check oh and he's got queen g4 rook takes c7
sacking the queen for me let's see if he finds it
he does andrew running with his king taking on e6
he goes for the business approach just extending
the attack look how many threats there are
okay bishop f6 but andrew holding on
he's still holding on but the problem is nihal
is also up upon so even if the attack one of
fails will no longer look at andrew
escaping to e8 he's extending this game
yeah you always have this hope of playing f5
knight moves bishop d6 okay he's going out
about a different way but he was trying to get
his bishop to c7 and nihal sort of simplifying
but now andrew's up upon or no no it's still
equal so he was up two points actually so this
is still better for white because of the weak
black king nihal recovers one of the extra pawns
and another one of those situations where he
can play this for for an hour and bleed clock
not that he needs to do that because of how
overwhelming the match score already is yeah
five minutes remaining in this match so we'll see
a few more games after this and um if you trade
queens the players can pretty much shake hands
right away which could happen right here yep
and despite the extra pawn of course
we know opposite colored bishops
greatly increase the drawing tendencies
not always there are exceptions to the rule
but here black's king is in the right place and
white just doesn't have enough to make the draw
and they will agree any second bishop can simply
tie itself to on b7 and no progress is possible
yeah and sometimes you're so caught up in the
middle of the match you're not even thinking
we've heard players before say that the idea of
milking the clock didn't even enter their head
because they're just so caught up in the moment or
that even though it's completely legal they don't
believe it that they view it as unsportsmanly um
i once played an over-the-board tournament as a
kid where my opponent at the beginning of the game
got sick and had to go to the restroom and i went
up to the tournament director and i asked him am
i supposed to stop the clock because my opponent
is sick now the tournament director happened
to be our dnd master for dungeons and dragons
his answer was well that depends mike
are you chaotic evil or lawful good
and actually that was a perfect answer
because there's no rule that says you have to
although some people view it as sportsmanly
however i would argue at internet chess
not that there's a lessening of morals but that
the clock is such a part of the game that using it
in any way legally to your advantage is aboveboard
completely agree with you mike i think that
there is sort of like a border you know there's
stuff that is questionable but i agree i think
that you can allow yourself more online
than over the board and i think that there
is a general acceptance of that among you know
among players uh i think that they usually don't
take objection to these kinds of things um
and players have different views on this some
are more into flagging some are less but
there is a spectrum and i think that usually
i always think that when a player does anything
to win it can be obnoxious but usually it's a
sign of respect and in the sense that he really
really wants to win so he values the opponent
so much that he will do anything to beat him you
know so he really it's important for him to win
so it can be thought of that way as well not
that you know there can't be obnoxious behavior
there absolutely can magical wizard01
says that he or she cannot see the score
because it's restricted and he or she is on
his school computer now i don't know how you're
accessing the chat i'm very proud of you but also
a little concerned as a former in-school educator
that you are skipping school but you're probably
at home i actually don't know what's going on in
the schooling world but let me just tell you a
magical wizard it's 16 to 7 in favor of nihal
sarin against andrew 10. we've got two minutes
left it's possible this is our final game but
they'd have to play a lot of moves probably we'll
see one more after this yeah yeah and uh we have
actually andrew mounting a tremendous attack here
against nehal's kane all trying to trade queens
you can consider even a sack on f6 now the
problem here for andrew is okay he trades
queens but the end game is completely winning
look at his pieces and messing together there
on the king side uh but yeah i mean crazy
stuff going on right now but we appreciate
people finding the time not that i advocate uh
doing this instead of paying attention in class
i would never do such a thing mike i would
never encourage people to procrastinate by
watching chess and in order to figure out who is
going to be the next star of the chess world in
10 years that's chess kids job chess kids job
is to get more kids playing chess so we can
eventually see them on chess.com and if any of you
out there are educators or parents you're involved
in your school pta you're a principal wait a
minute are you a superintendent of a district
if you are please email schools chesskid.com we
will make sure that every kid in your district
is able to get access to chess and here's what i
want to see i want to see rook b7 followed by a3
bishop rook before me oh look at you and he goes
for a slightly different mating now this is as
effective because he is going to pick off that
knight hole and now take all of black's pawns
and uh knee hall yeah so this is over now again i
think you're doing awesome work with chess kid and
uh i'm very passionate about the cause of bringing
chess to to everyone i think it helps in ways that
perhaps people don't realize now you know a
lot more about this than i do mike but to me
people always try to measure or just chess make
you better at math scores but i think chess builds
so many skills that are not always quantifiable
by a test i agree you know so many kids grow up
playing team sports and they have to win or lose
but they can always sort of diminish a win or a
loss based on teammates but in chess you're all
out there by yourself you've got to fix all the
problems yourself you did some great work in the
bay area we're happy to have you as the resident
grand master at the charlotte chess center and
that game was finished with 14 seconds left so
it is i'm not going to call it bonus chess but we
should be able to squeeze one more game in because
there was definitely time on the clock and andrew
gets his first win in the bullet right in the
penultimate game indeed in a very good game there
with an attack keeping his his coombs cool uh now
we will i think that the players are probably not
aware the time has not expired yet now we'll see
it looks like they might actually be done let's
see they definitely there was time remaining
okay they are done so looks like the players have
agreed to end the match here and a score of 16 to
eight in favor of grand master nihal saren
who defeats grand master andrew tang um so
what a match by nihal winning all of the sections
incredible show um as things somehow got out of
control for andrew um by the three-minute section
yeah nice to see him come back there though i feel
good for him that he was able to win that final
game now he's done like 100 game bullet matches
against magnus so i'm sure he doesn't need
the pad on the back i'm sure that would feel
a little bit like i was uh some sort of evonucular
commentator um but uh indeed yeah so i think
um we're gonna just stay right here as we're
getting the interview or are we going on break
i think we're going in a very short break uh and
when we return we will have these two gladiators
for you and we will have some questions and we'll
have the interview so very quick break and we
will be right back don't go anywhere we have
a really interesting interview coming right up
so
welcome back ladies and gentlemen we have
grand masters neil sieren and andrew tang
here for you for a quick interview um right
after the match nihal congratulations on your
victory fantastic play uh there was a point
in the match when things kind of turned around
and you won quite a lot of games
was it sort of a conscious change
uh did you sort of change your approach as the
five-minute section drew to a to a closer did
you feel like you sort of just got more warmed up
walk us through how you felt throughout the match
and yeah the match was very close throughout
and um the five minutes was very tough for me
somehow andrew was playing extremely well and
very fast and at some point i was just trying to
not get so angry at some point it just started
going well for me and yeah then they're just good
now nihal a few days ago when you saw that andrew
tang won the knockout by winning all those matches
and you found out he would be your opponent you
could make the argument that this is the toughest
one versus 16 match up ever for the one seed
what were your thoughts when you found out
that andrew tang would be your opponent yeah yeah
it was i knew it was going to be very tough and
andrew is of course very fast and
strong and yeah i'm a big fan of him
i see you smiling andrew dude did you know he was
a fan of yours i mean you played many games but
that's that's flattering um what about those three
matches you had to win in the knockout to get here
andrew um i don't think a 20 year old would be
tired out by matches especially when you had
several days it's not like you played them
yesterday but was there any fatigue from those
matches i don't think so if anything it's like
early in the morning i just haven't quite woken
up yet that makes sense are you surprised that you
did better in the five minute i mean i'm sure you
went into today thinking you would win everybody
would but you know your result your results were
better in the five minute do you think that's an
underappreciated part of your game yeah i think
okay i'm not so bad at puts but of course i expect
to do better when the time is lower so yeah well
well you played very very well one final question
for you nihal um do you sort of prepare very
intensely for these matches or do you kind of
keep a clear head where on the spectrum do you lie
i don't prefer so hard for these
matches but i do check a bit and
um i hate to ask you a gotcha question but don
you and i see donya seems to think that if we
had a competition on world capitals that he might
be the favorite but nihal i don't know if this
is verifiable your wikipedia page says that you
knew 190 capitals and country flags by the time
you were three now first of all is that true or is
wikipedia being a little bit generous with that oh
i don't exactly know when i was very young maybe
i knew a lot but now i don't know even half of it
oh you don't know half okay sensible probably
it's not fair to give you a gotcha question then
we were gonna quiz you with a couple of countries
but we'll uh we'll maybe pass on that so yeah well
you've both of you have earned your arrests thank
you so much nihal and andrew for a fantastic match
congratulations uh to you nihal and best of luck
in your remaining matches and uh great play andrew
so thanks to both of you uh you've definitely
earned your rest yeah you've both acquired a bunch
of fans and nihal i think your entire country can
go to sleep right now i'm sure that they're all
we did not lose any fans even though you were
pulling away so i know it's one o'clock in india
but uh congratulations to to the entire country of
india because you still have five representatives
in the chess kid junior speed chess championship
all five are still alive so um thanks to you both
for an exciting match and i'm sure that a lot
of you have gained a lot of people's respect and
we're gonna see a lot more of you because both of
you guys i mean you're you're still too young to
i don't know to do most things in life
a lot your future's uh very bright so
happy to have you guys thank you thanks all right
well ladies and gentlemen as that amazing match
comes to an end we will just quickly remind
you of the epic matches still to come and uh
tomorrow i believe and i got this wrong once but
i think we have our generic ic against gukesh
two incredibly strong young indian players that
will be coming your way same time uh 12 eastern
9 a.m pacific so that will be tomorrow a great
way to kick off the weekend but what a match it
was today an amazing performance by nihal mike uh
any final thoughts on your end as we just forecast
the predicted match in knee hall one step closer
to actually fulfilling that uh i'll just say i'm
gonna go ahead and ruin every chess fans complete
weekend by saying that sunday the next american up
is sam sevien against i'm in tabatabe who's uh
a player who have only come to know in the last
years that's going to be an amazing one as well
my weekend is ruined because i know i'm going to
watch both of these even if i'm outside so great
stuff today very exciting five minute section
um and uh our smarter chess predictions that nihal
sarin will be the predicted winner uh the funny
thing about this prediction is if you're a 60
favorite in each match mathematically that does
not necessarily mean you'll win it all and i'm
not going to get into the problem of statistics
but knee hall does survive and move on to the
second round and he will play the winner of the
smirnoff radwani match so i'm excited about all
of the month to come of all the other junior speed
chess championship players and happy that chess
kid is here to help bring it to you absolutely
um well this was an incredible match um i had just
a blast all of the sections were competitive new
hall taking it away as the three-minute section
began um and as we come to an end just wanted to
say a very very big shout out and thank you
to the thousands of people watching across
platforms and participating and cheering on the
respective players uh and mike it was a pleasure
to commentate uh with you as well the time just
flew by thanks daniel we will now perry's lagruska
and get ready for the match tomorrow absolutely
see everyone later stay safe and see you tomorrow
so
do